hello everyone welcome to the July 2023
ask me anything addition to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll if you've been listening to
mindscape for a while you know the
general idea here uh every Monday we
have a podcast I'm usually interviewing
somebody sometimes I do a solo episode
and once a month it's this ask me
anything episode and I always mentioned
that these are supported by patreon
supporters so you can sign up to be a
patreon supporter yourself go to
www.patreon.com Sean M Carroll and
pledge a dollar or two dollars or a
million dollars however you feel like
for each episode of mindscape It's very
easy to do it's very easy to cancel if
you lose interest and it's much
appreciated by me as well as actually
getting some tangible benefits these
questions for the amas come from patreon
supporters those are the people who are
allowed to ask the questions also
patreon supporters get ad-free versions
of the podcast cast and the reason why
I'm bringing this up front and center
right now is because we are
experimenting with a new benefit for
patreon supporters which is that I'm
going to try to do a little reflection
video also audio version immediately
after every podcast so every time I
interview someone the amas don't count
I'm not gonna do reflection after the
amas you've just listen to me talk for
two or three hours you don't need that
but after I interview someone I'm going
to try to do a little reflection on what
I got out of the podcast that just
happened you know what I think about it
why I had it in the first place whatever
is on my mind at that time just a couple
minutes very informal uh nothing very
serious or anything but it is there on
patreon it is nowhere else so if that's
the kind of thing you might be
interested in that's one more reason to
sign up as a patreon supporter for
mindscape you know as always enormous
gratitude from me to everyone who
listens to the podcast whether you're
patreon supporter or not special
gratitude for those who chip in a dollar
two per episode it is very much
appreciated and this month lots of
questions lots of things lots of science
this month so let's go
[Music]
thank you
Chris Mason says it seems like every day
there's another article or news report
highlighting the existential risk of AI
artificial intelligence do you think
there is a risk associated with AI
development that is serious enough to
Warrant such media attention it feels to
me just like the LHC black hole scare
all over again
yeah I think there are some similarities
there it's actually a very tricky
question you know I have opinions about
it but I don't want to act as if my
opinions are set in stone I think this
is something where we should be applying
some thought process to this uh maybe at
a more calm deliberative level than
we've done so far you know there's
clearly an argument to be made about
existential Risk by existential risk we
mean really not just something bad
happens but all of humanity is
extinguished right the end of the human
race that's an existential risk now this
seems hard to imagine exactly what would
happen but I think that the argument
goes something like
AI is something very different uh we
don't know what its capacities would be
if we work on an analogy with human
beings if we take seriously in other
words the idea that AIS are truly
intelligent then we can easily imagine
making AIS that are more intelligent
than human beings and human beings are
the ones who built the AIS in the first
place so these more intelligent agents
will be able to do at least that and
more and that opens up a whole bunch of
possibilities if the values of the AI
are not aligned with our human values
they might not care about us They Might
Be indifferent or even absolutely
against our existence we don't know and
I think the argument goes even if it's a
small chance it's enough of a chance
that it's something we should worry
about just because you know the whole
end of all humanity is pretty bad so
even if the chance is very small if it's
non-negligible then we should take it
very seriously so I have lots of
problems with this argument
um a couple of them just very briefly
are number one the more or less uh what
is the word not the anthropomorphic way
in which we are borrowing the word
intelligence and applying it to AI we
use the word intelligence to talk about
human beings in many different ways it's
a sort of a catch-all term for many
different kinds of capacities from the
ability to be successful in life to the
ability to do well in standardized tests
and I think it's a little bit of a
mistake a little bit too anthropomorphic
to Simply say well AI if it gets to be
intelligent and more intelligent than us
will be like humans but smarter and
therefore better than us AI is a
different kind of thing they're not
embodied necessarily they didn't grow up
through Evolution they don't have the
impulses and motivations and feelings
that we have that's not to say they're
better or worse or less or more capable
out there but they're different and so I
do think that it's important to
recognize what those differences are and
not to be too glib about putting
everything on a single unified scale of
intelligence
another thing that I worry about is the
idea that well you know the harm is so
huge that even if it's very unlikely we
have to take it very seriously I get
that argument but I think it's a little
too quick you know I I use the argument
speaking of the Lac black hole scare all
over again I use the argument in my book
um the particle at the End of the
Universe I said look when you open a jar
of spaghetti sauce
to put on your pasta for dinner in the
evening is there a chance that in that
jar of spaghetti sauce There is has been
a mutation
which has created a virulent pathogen
that when released by you opening the
jar of pasta sauce will spread out into
the ecosystem and kill every living
being
well strictly speaking as we always say
here when it comes to Scientific
questions if the question is is there a
chance or is it possible that the answer
is always yes there is some chance that
every time you open that jar of pasta
sauce you're going to wipe out the whole
human race and how much benefit do you
really get from that jar of pasta sauce
right so can you make an argument that
even though it's unlikely that that
pathogen will be created nevertheless
you should not open it because the
consequences would be so dire and no
that kind of argument doesn't work to
stop people from opening their jars of
pasta sauce and part of it is that we
don't have a very good way of
consistently multiplying a big number by
a small number the big number in this
case being the harm that would be caused
by this particular action in in
principle possibly and the small number
being the probability that that action
is actually going to lead to that harm
we are very bad at that kind of
mathematical operation so I don't think
it's okay to Simply say AI has a chance
of extinguishing the whole human race
and therefore we should take that chance
seriously you have to be a little bit
more specific
and the people who are worried about
these dangers are in my experience not
very good at telling us precisely how AI
is supposed to do this what is the
actual scenario that we are worried
about
I do think meanwhile that there are many
things to be worried about when it comes
to AI how it's going to affect our
consumption of news and information uh
how it's going to affect careers and
jobs for writers and artists and people
like that how it will help people in all
sorts of different ways all sorts of
different conversations we should be
having
I think that those very much more
plausible real world near-term dangers
are what we should be focusing on not
the existential risk kind of dangers
especially because I think that the
kinds of safeguards we will put in place
to make sure that
medium-sized risks from AI do not happen
will also help us prevent the big risks
from AI so I don't see much point in
worrying about the science fictiony
literally killing all human beings kinds
of scenarios yes if it happens that
would be especially bad but the kinds of
things that we can do to prevent it from
happening can be motivated and much more
reasonable sensible high probability
ways so I don't personally worry about
existential risk from AI I worry about
other kinds of risks from AI
Paul torrex says Brian Lowry on the
recent podcast reminded both you and me
of Hugo Mercier and his analysis of
reason as a primarily social activity
question in your view is there one true
logic that is can one say the statements
in set a imply B without adding
according to logic system l or without
implicitly expressing from my standpoint
as an inherent of logic system l
no I mean it's clearly not just one true
logic any logician will tell you that
there's all sorts of different kinds of
logic um that we use for different
purposes under different assumptions and
so forth I am not a philosopher of logic
or the foundations of logic or anything
like that so I can't go through all the
arguments back and forth but there
absolutely are different kinds of logic
I'm not quite sure how that connects
with the uh analysis of reason as a
primary social activity except that you
know just to be super clear here when
Hugo was talking about reason as a
primary primarily social activity wasn't
reason that he was focusing on it was
reasons plural the difference being by
reasons he means the fact that when you
do something you think of it as being
done for a reason okay so in other words
you offer an explanation that's a little
bit different than reasoning when you're
adding two numbers you're reasoning but
you're not offering reasons you're just
going through some steps what Hugo
Mercier was mostly concerned with is the
social activity of explaining to other
people why you're doing something or
they should do something or something
should be done by Society or something
like that even though we
closely relate reason reasons and
reasoning they're not the same thing
they're related to each other but it's
the reasons the offering of reasons that
he was really focusing on
shahil says energy can neither be
created nor destroyed rather it can only
be transformed or transferred from one
form or another that's the law of energy
conservation
when the when space and time itself is
evolving changing expanding and in a way
creating itself isn't energy also
created in the time Cosmic time scale of
the last 13.8 billion years
uh yeah absolutely created or it can
increase or it can be destroyed and
there is no rule
or at least it is not correct to state
the rule as the total amount of energy
in the universe is constant uh I wrote a
blog post about this years ago so if you
Google the phrase energy is not
conserved you will probably find my blog
post about this and it's a tricky thing
because when you have space time itself
being dynamical as you do in general
relativity there is more than one
definition of the word energy okay
some of those definitions
have the property that the energy is
conserved but they are also usually
trivial like this just the energy is
always zero for a closed Universe in
general relativity for example so that's
conserved it's zero now with zero then
Etc but it's not actually telling you
anything interesting about the physical
configuration of stuff
there's another definition of energy
which is just the energy of the stuff
within the universe the matter particles
the radiation the dark energy all that
stuff
that is a number that you can add up and
it is absolutely not conserved simple
fact okay it can go up or it can go down
when the universe is mostly dominated by
radiation that energy goes down as time
goes on when the energy is mostly
dominated by dark energy on the other
hand it goes up as time goes on it turns
out that there is still a rule that is
obeyed but the rule does not simply say
energy can neither be created or
destroyed the total amount of energy
responds to what space-time is doing in
a very particular way there's also
subtleties in quantum mechanics uh you
can also have energy of the quantum
state that you are experiencing as an
observer change when you do a Quantum
measurement I think there might be a
question about that later
Samson asks a priority question recall
that priority questions are granted to
every patreon supporter once per
lifetime you can ask a question and I
will do my best to answer it so Samson
is asking his
I really enjoyed your conversation on
the social self with Brian Lowry when we
use sentences like I am have a self a
body or mind the obvious constant is
that I is not X which makes me feel that
I is real so I'm sorry I'm trying to
read the notation here that's capital I
equals tilde capital X in logic that
tilde often would mean not but in
physics or math it might mean
approximately equal to so I'm not quite
sure what is being meant here
anyway the question continues I've
learned that in physics capital I stands
for electric current which in turn is a
stream of charged particles I find that
heuristically the lorentz force formula
I equals Q the electric charge times e
plus v cross B
that's correct
um
No actually that's not correct sorry
that is the force for the that is the
I'm in the middle of Samson's questions
here maybe let me let me finish reading
Samson's question
could that
could this could we describe a dual
entity a body and a contingent mind with
the electrical term describing the
current conducted by a neural network
system one and the Magnetic term
describing the induced current by an
immersion magnetosphere like the B field
system 2. for me Q moves therefore b b
feels I I feels b i therefore feel that
I am and to paraphrase Einstein
questions as to the seat of the self
have no point the question is can the
physical I stand for the psychological I
can I be reduced to I okay there's a lot
going on here
um so the the formula QE plus v cross B
is not the formula for the electrical
current okay that is the formula for the
force on a Charged body with charge Q in
the presence of an electric field e and
a magnetic field B when the particle is
moving at velocity V that's a different
thing than the current the current is
the total amount of electric charge
passing by any particular small area
element per unit time so
the formula doesn't quite mean what what
we said there and also you know that
that's a very specific formula within
electromagnetism there's other formulas
for forces and for things that mean
different things so nothing in that
formula has anything to do with bodies
or Minds it all has to do with
electricity in a very specific theory of
the electromagnetic field that was
written down by Professor Maxwell and
his predecessors I think it would be a
mistake to try to analogize it too
closely to the eye of the self or
anything like that the the fact that the
letter i is used for electrical current
uh shouldn't lead you to think of that
as being related in any way to the
psychological eye as in myself
Paul Conte says I was wondering if you
had any opinions or observations
regarding a recent study suggesting that
dark matter is composed of very low mass
bosonic particles which can behave as a
Bose Einstein condensate and take on
Quantum wave-like properties on large
scales this may be related to something
known as fuzzy cold dark matter
so
I don't have that many thoughts on the
recent study there there was a recent
study I know it's being referred to uh
sorry let's back up
the most popular candidate for what the
dark matter is is the weekly interacting
massive particle the wimp for many
reasons it would make sense if there was
a particle that was weak sorry weekly
interacting electrically neutral stable
and has a mass of about you know the
Higgs boson mass or maybe a little bit
heavier Mass something like that
hundreds of gev at least one GV at least
the mass of the proton or much higher
but there are other examples of Dark
Matter candidates that are not weakly
interacting massive particles one is the
Axion the Axion is a very light particle
10 to the minus 5 electron volts whereas
the proton is a billion electron volts
right so the the Axion is much much
lighter but it's produced in a very
different way in the early universe so
that even though it's very low mass
unlike neutrinos that are very low mass
but rapidly moving because it doesn't
take much energy to get them to move the
Axion is very low mass and almost at
rest in the very early universe
so Axion still count as cold Dark Matter
even though they're very low mass
the idea of fuzzy cold dark matter or
other things like that Bose Einstein
condensate Dark Matter Etc are
or other other kinds of hypothetical
particles that are even lower in mass
and you might know that in particle
physics mass is inversely proportional
to Compton wavelength Compton wavelength
is roughly speaking the smallest size
you can squeeze a particle into so a
very very low mass particle will
necessarily be spread out all over the
place and the relevance for dark matter
is if the the wavelength of these
Quantum particles is astrophysical in
scale
then the Dynamics of those particles
will be very different than particles
that are sort of point-like and can just
move in different ways so I think that
that scenario overall is actually
interesting and promising the difference
yeah the reason why it's maybe not as
popular as axions or wimps is that
axions and wimps were both invented for
completely other reasons they were not
invented just to be the dark matter they
solve other problems and they have bonus
Duty as being the Dark Matter whereas
this fuzzy Dark Matter stuff is part of
a large category of models where it was
purely invented just to be the dark
matter and look maybe that's how it is
we don't know but if you have one
hypothetical particle that can solve two
problems at once that's considered to be
better now the finally the new uh result
that came out was a claim that certain
observations of galaxies and clusters of
galaxies and their gravitational lensing
properties is better fitted to fuzzy
very very low mass Dark Matter models
than it is to ordinary wimp or Axion
models I have no real idea whether or
not that study is correct or not I will
uh leave it you know I think that this
is the kind of thing where even if it is
correct it's going to need more analysis
more careful thought about it so I'm
going to wait until that careful thought
and extra analysis happens if it if more
and more data come in more and more
analyzes are done and they continue to
move in that direction I think it'd be
super super interesting and important
Sean Miller says whatever Consciousness
is it seems to reveal itself in
organisms capable of perception from
this perspective physics and philosophy
matter and Consciousness meet in
perception perception seems to add
something new to the physical world
which is information for an agent to act
on EG a measure of surprise in Shannon's
sense I'm wondering if you could say
more about your thoughts on information
as it applies to physics for example
does information and by extension
surprise exist in a universe without
perception
you know I think of information
conceptually as a kind of thing that is
very similar to energy it's not the same
thing I'm not saying information is
energy or anything like that but they
are on the same conceptual playing field
if I ask the question does energy exist
in a universe without perception
well your first your first instinct is
to say yes you know there are still
particles they have energy or whatever
forget about details of quantum field
Theory let's just make our lives easier
think about particles moving under the
influence of forces and we can assign
energies to them okay
then you might think yeah you know there
are particles they have energy energy
exists whether or not there's anyone
looking at it or noticing that it's
there but there's another thing you
could say which is that
without people to talk about it you know
the particles just do what they do you
know they follow the laws of motion they
don't know they're following Laws of
Motion because they're just particles
but they move on their trajectories you
know they they obey certain patterns
that are built into the fabric of the
universe so they have certain behaviors
but you don't ever need to use the word
energy to describe such particles you
could just say what the particles do
where they are what their velocities are
and so forth energy turns out to be a
really useful way of thinking about the
particles because it's conserved for
closed systems you can help yourself
analyzing the behavior of things if you
think in terms of energy
so it is useful to us to ascribe energy
to physical systems I think information
is exactly the same way I think you
could imagine the universe doing what it
does without ever referring to
information you don't need to use that
kind of vocabulary but it's useful to
use that kind of vocabulary so does
information exist in the universe
without perception it exists but there's
no one there to talk about it so it's
not really kind of necessary part of
that description I don't think there's
anything spooky or even related to
Consciousness about information when you
see a footprint on the beach
you are able to infer that there was
probably a foot that passed by right
somebody probably walked on the beach
there is information contained in the
footprint the amount of information
contained in the footprint I would say
is the same whether or not you see the
footprint there or not but the
usefulness of the information is very
different I think it is interesting to
think about
how information came to be used by
conscious perceiving creatures over the
history of the universe but I don't want
to give those conscious perceiving
creatures credit for the existence of
the information in the first place
Ali alavi says Some people prefer not to
tell their thoughts because of others
reactions for instance they avoid
discussing specific religions
differences between males and females or
Palestinian and Israeli issues I'd like
to know your thoughts about this
phenomenon and subjects you have such
considerations for if any
you know I hope that almost everyone
takes other people's reactions into
account when they prefer to tell or not
tell their thoughts that's just called
being polite right like being a
considerate person I don't say every
single thing in my head at all moments
in time I choose certain things to
express and certain things not to
express maybe I think that I have a
thought but it's not a very interesting
thought maybe I have a thought but it
would be rude to say it out loud there's
nothing weird or wrong about that the
general theory of when to say things and
when not to say things is undoubtedly
complicated and subtle in many
considerations come into play sometimes
sometimes it's right to be rude for
whatever reason sometimes it's right to
hurt people's feelings sometimes uh you
want to say things and you know other
people are going to disagree with you
but you just think it's the right thing
to do and it's time to stand up
sometimes people just like to be
obnoxious and therefore they say things
that they didn't really need to say but
they kind of like to get a rise out of
people all of these are real human-sized
things that are important and valid to
take into consideration I think the only
mistake to make here is to be
unreflective and overly simplistic about
questions of when you should express
your thoughts and when you should not
says you've repeatedly expressed your
skepticism of invoking the typicality of
our own perspective EG and cosmology
well I agree that amounts to a leap in
logic isn't it arguable that it is a
copernican way of uploading's Occam's
razor there are any number of ways of
being atypical so we shouldn't so we
usually have no basis for assuming any
one of them on the other hand there is
basically one way of being typical so we
at least have something to go on when we
say for example what would a distant
region of the universe feel like
assuming our neighborhood is typical
well I think that this has to be you
know just carefully adjudicated here
because there's different Notions or
ways in which things can be typical I am
just not typical I am not a typical
collection of atoms in the universe I am
not a typical environment in the
universe I'm not even a typical person
on Earth that's blatantly obvious in
many many ways so it's not that we have
no information and are therefore trying
to do our best we have information when
I say we shouldn't assume we're typical
I mean we should use the information we
have and there's no reason to assume
that given that information we are still
typical even after conditionalizing over
everything that we know because that
information tells us very blatantly a
whole bunch of ways in which we
obviously are not typical if you knew no
better then I would see an argument for
saying that in some sense we're typical
but we know better so I want to take
that seriously when you say you know
what would a distant region of the
universe feel like assuming our
neighborhood is typical well our
neighborhood is not typical again we're
close to a star most parts of the
universe are not close to a star right
so what exactly is meant by that do you
mean is our observable universe typical
among the set of all sets of observable
universes we have no way of knowing that
you might have a specific cosmological
model and which make case you can make
some probabilistic statements but I have
simply no way of knowing whether or not
parts of the universe outside what I can
actually observe are the same as mine in
the absence of that particular
cosmological model so that's why it's
important to have a model and then you
can reason within it but these blanket
statements about our typicality I think
are leading us astray in various ways
Brendan says if your wife hypothetically
became religious do you think that you
that would put friction on the marriage
or is it possible that a married couple
can still be loving and supportive
despite the polar opposite views on
religion
I think that depends a lot on what you
mean by become religious there's many
different ways to become religious and
you know forgetting about me and my
actual wife just thinking hypothetically
about a couple
um you know there's a way to be
religious where you kind of say you're
religious but it doesn't really affect
your life in any way like it doesn't
affect your behavior but you just say
yeah I believe in God or whatever but
you know you're still the same person
you are I certainly think that an
atheist and someone like that could get
along and have a very loving
relationship unless the atheist side of
the story was more of the atheist person
insisted on some internal coherence to
their Partners World Views right uh you
know I I can I would absolutely be
sympathetic to a view that said if
you're religious at all it should affect
your life of course it again once
depends on what you mean by religious
there's a form of being religious where
you believe that God is just the
universe and doesn't intervene anything
that happens then you know knock
yourself out but if you believe that
there's a God up there that judges you
and cares about you and once you behave
in certain ways and you will get
punished or rewarded depending on how
you behave in my mind if you're that
person if you have that beliefs then
that would have a huge effect on how you
lived your life so I could imagine an
atheist being a little worried about the
hypocrisy of someone who claimed to
believe that but it didn't actually
affect their lives
for a lot of ways of being religious it
does affect your life very much and it
could turn you into a different kind of
person you know there are people who
believe terrible things in my mind and
they justify them on the basis of their
religious beliefs I would not want to be
married to someone like that so I think
you have to be a little bit more
specific about what kind of religious
beliefs were hypothetically invoking
here
Astro Nobel says I just read a very
interesting article about the
information Paradox in black holes to my
surprise a statement was dropped out of
thin air about the monogamy of
entanglement it was stated that one
particle one qubit can be entangled with
at most one other and then the question
goes on but I can answer it from here uh
the either the article you're reading or
you're reading of it was a little bit
casual there I think there is a
principle called the monogamy of
entanglement but it does not say that
one particle can only be entangled with
at most one other what it says is that
two particles can not be maximally
entangled with more than each other at
the same time so there's a certain
maximal amount of entanglement that
let's say one spin okay if you have two
particles both of which have spin if
they're both in separate superpositions
of spin up and spin down then there's
zero entanglement there
measuring one tells you nothing about
the state of the other
if they are maximally entangled then
measuring 1 tells you everything about
the state of the other you know they can
both be in superpositions but if they're
in entangled superposition let's say
with the spins aligned with each other
then by measuring one to be spin up you
know the other one is spin down that is
maximal entanglement and you can only be
maximally entangled with one other
particle at the same time that's the
principle of the monogamy entanglement
very often you have partial amounts of
entanglement that's crucially important
in the world in fact in the vacuum in
empty space every mode of every Quantum
field that you have is a little bit
entangled with every mode of the quantum
field everywhere else in the universe so
that's perfectly allowed just not at the
maximum level the amount of entanglement
goes down as you get further and further
apart in the vacuum in the quantum
vacuum state
Euro Michelli says how sure are we at
this point that the famed particle found
at the LHC really is the Higgs boson
we're basically 100 sure to the extent
that you can be we're sure enough to not
be worried about that question anymore
when we first so one one it to back up a
little bit here what do you mean by it
really is the Higgs boson it's like
saying you know do
um Jews and Christians and Muslims
believe in the same God well you know
what do you mean by God there the Higgs
boson is a hypothetical construct that
plays a certain role in the electro-week
theory of nature it breaks the electric
weak symmetry it provides Mass to
electrons and other kinds of fermions
and so forth so the particle that we
found is doing that therefore it is the
Higgs boson you can also however have
more elaborate models where more than
one particle is responsible for these
features there are supersymmetric models
with several hex bosons at once so I
would say that we know that we found a
Higgs boson and Higgs bosano a Higgs
boson this is a boson and it's doing
higgs-like things it clearly seems to be
coupling to other particles in the way
that the Higgs boson is supposed to
couple okay we've measured that that was
not true in 2012 we had indications when
we first found it that
we so what you do is you never see the
Higgs boson at the LHC okay what you see
is it decays into other particles and
what you can do is predict the relative
rate of Decay into other kinds of
particles and you can compare that with
the data so that's what we do we didn't
just see a Higgs boson there on a
photograph we saw some extra photons
some extra other particles and both the
absolute and relative amounts of these
other particles were consistent with
what you would expect from the Higgs
boson nowadays we have much more data
and it can keep saying the same thing it
keeps telling us that the decays of this
new particle are exactly what you would
expect from the Higgs boson so we are
pretty sure
I hope getting that right genitsos says
if we could isolate a group of particles
from its environment that was large
enough for us to measure its
gravitational effect presumably we could
observe how its wave function
superposition is related to gravity
do we know it would happen from such an
experimental setup or could this only
come from a quantum theory of gravity is
our inability to perform these
experiments just because our lack of
Technology
you don't need a quantum theory of
gravity for that unless
there are some proposals out there that
are very let's say non-standard and they
try to treat gravity as purely classical
if they just refuse to admit that
there's something called quantum gravity
so I don't find that those proposals are
very promising let's put them aside
um the details of quantum gravity as
long as there is quantum gravity don't
really affect how a large massive object
in a Quantum superposition would
gravitate that is just pretty
straightforward from the from the point
of view of effective field theories
which I have sometimes talked about and
we'll talk about a lot more in the
upcoming Volume 2 of the biggest ideas
in the universe I know I will talk about
it because I've written that part I've
written the whole draft it's in the
publication process now sometimes next
year it will come out and we talk about
effective field theories the idea that
you don't need to know all the details
you don't need to know what would happen
in extreme circumstances at the Big Bang
or black holes you can just talk about
weak gravitational fields and every
gravitational field in the solar system
is weak by these standards weak just
means you're not close to making a black
hole okay under those circumstances we
know perfectly well what quantum gravity
predicts almost
independently of the specifics of the
model
so yes the inability to actually perform
these experiments is entirely because
they are just too hard to perform you
know when we do measurements of
gravitational fields we struggle against
the fact that gravity is a very weak
Force we can measure the gravitational
field of things with Avogadro's numbers
of particles right macroscopic things
measuring grams or more we can measure
those gravitational fields but that's a
huge number of particles you're never
going to keep something with that many
particles free from D coherence and
collapsing its wave function so to
actually have a macroscopically large
self-gravitating system being a
superposition of being in two different
places is very very difficult to even
imagine doing any time in the
foreseeable future
Michael benedson says I don't quite
understand your take on the anthropic
principle in your Great Courses on the
Arrow of time you formulate the
anthropic principle as follows if there
are many different conditions throughout
our universe then intelligent beings
like ourselves will only find ourselves
in the middle of those conditions that
are compatible with us existing what I
don't understand is why you need the
first Clause if there are many different
conditions throughout the Universe why
doesn't the anthropic principle apply
even if there's only one universe or one
set of conditions if I can imagine two
sets of conditions only one of which is
conducive to life then I wouldn't be
surprised myself I wouldn't be surprised
to find myself in that one even if the
universe with the non-suitable
conditions didn't exist
well sure there is a principle which you
might call the super duper weak
anthropic principle which simply says
the universe we observe is necessarily
compatible with our existence
it's true that's not very useful though
right that doesn't tell us anything at
all about anything we already knew that
the anthropic principle that I am
referring to has explanatory power if
you imagine there's just a single
Universe where the conditions were the
same everywhere and it was not
compatible with the existence of
intelligent life then we wouldn't be
here talking about it but if you imagine
a kind of a Multiverse or at least a
kind of very big universes where
conditions are different from place to
place then there is a different
consideration that comes in namely that
there is a selection effect
namely that you as intelligent Observer
are not going to be privy to an unbiased
view of the universe you are necessarily
going to find yourself in the subset of
the universe that allows for you to
exist in it
so it's not that The Logical conclusion
that the universe is compatible with our
existence necessitates some kind of
Multiverse or different conditions is
that the explanatory role played by that
selection effect is different if you
have many different parts of the
Universe versus just a uniform Universe
everywhere
riparian
says is it possible to conduct a
hypothetical experiment where
gravitational wave interference occurs
and where areas of constructive and
destructive gravitational wave
interference are present if such were
possible with sampling of areas of
destructive interference yield a finding
of true zero gravity in the universe and
where space-time is not curved
well yes and no is the kind of answer
here
um hypothetically you could absolutely
have a gravitational wave interference
I'm sure that you actually do do that
real gravitational waves go up and down
they Cross by each other and they will
interfere constructively or
destructively that's true
you're not going to detect that anytime
soon because again gravity is a very
weak Force it's hard to detect
gravitational waves at all think about
light it was very hard it took hundreds
of years for people to measure
interference patterns in light but they
had measured light a long time before
that so now we're in a situation where
we've just measured gravitational waves
measuring interference patterns in them
is harder than that okay
furthermore to the second part of the
question uh if there were destructive
interference that would not be enough to
say that this truly zero gravity in the
universe because the gravitational field
is complicated this is why you need to
learn riemani in Geometry when you learn
general relativity because the way that
we describe the curvature of space-time
is mathematically very intricate and
space-time curvature has many different
components so if you had destructive
gravitational wave interference you
would be zeroing out some components of
what we call the Riemann tensor the
curvature tensor that tells us all the
different ways in which the
gravitational field is measured all the
different ways in which space time is
curved but you wouldn't necessarily be
zeroing out all of them so if what you
mean by true zero gravity is literally
flat space time in some region of
non-zero extent you would not quite get
that just by doing destructive
gravitational wave interference you have
to work harder than that
Nicola Ivanov says it seems to me that
there are some unstated assumptions in
the boltzmann brain thought experiment
the explicit assumptions are for an
infinitely large and forever existing
universe that there are random thermal
or Quantum fluctuations in a featureless
universe in a state of heat death and
that small fluctuations are more likely
than large ones however there's also the
unstated assumption that functioning
complex structures like brains or our
observable universe can pop out of a
vacuum in an instant without an
incompressible history of their
formation if you assume that complex
structures like brains need time to
develop as functioning entities and that
this time is incompressible it's their
evolutionary history that would change I
think there's a missing word here in the
question would their evolutionary
history change the discussion around
boltzmann brains so no it would not
because this is not an unstated
assumption this is just a true fact that
you don't need an incompressible
evolutionary history to make a brain or
anything else complex and macroscopic
by the way it is not true that these
things that even in the conventional
boltzmann brain story it is not true
that these fluctuations happen
instantaneously it takes a long time you
basically would most likely witness a
very long series of individually
unlikely events assembling the brain out
of vacuum fluctuations because the most
common way the most likely way for a
brain to appear is just the time reverse
of the most likely future of a brain
that is out there in the middle of
nothing so the reason why this is a
known fact rather than assumption is
because we can certainly imagine a
configuration
that looks like empty space plus a brain
or plus a living organism or plus
whatever you want to have plus a planet
whatever you want to have plus empty
space around it we can imagine that in
an otherwise empty universe and we can
hypothetically imagine what happens to
that toward the future right we can
project a little bit forward in time and
the most likely way for that
configuration that we started with to
assemble out of thermal random
fluctuations is just the time reverse of
that it looks like a movie being played
backwards I actually wrote a paper about
this with former mindscape guest Anthony
Aguirre and also Matt Johnson we wrote a
paper about exactly this the most likely
way to make these complex structures is
as time reverses of their most likely
future Decay paths and those will
generally be long but much much shorter
than you know evolutionary time scales
or anything like that we you and I live
in a world that is entirely conditional
realized on the existence of a very
strong thermodynamic Arrow of time so
when we see a brain we naturally say oh
that must have Arisen out of some
complex evolutionary process just like
when we see an ice cube we go oh yes
there's probably a freezer or something
like that right when you see a book oh
someone wrote the book when you see a
footprint ah someone's foot was there
all of these very intuitive sensible
Impressions come about because you have
an arrow of time if you didn't have an
arrow of time all of those implications
inferences would be completely
unjustified the world is not like that
in the absence of an arrow of time so
you can do the math and you can find
that Far and Away the best most likely
ways of making complex systems is by
randomly fluctuating them into existence
over the course of many many little sub
fluctuations
Chris V has another priority question
I've heard David Deutsch say that
Quantum Computing is a short proof for
the many worlds interpretation I believe
his case is that you can devise a
computation that cannot be computed in a
reasonable time even if every particle
in the visible universe or acting as a
transistor in a classical computer
if the computation can be completed via
a quantum computer then it can only be
have only have been completed via
interactions with other worlds or
similar is this really the case or have
I misunderstood
I believe that David Deutsch has said
things like that and I I don't actually
agree with the statement
it depends on what your collection of
Alternatives is to many worlds I think
with that there is an argument being
made there but two things are going on
one is
I don't count other parts of the wave
function as necessarily other worlds in
particular I don't count them as other
worlds until decoherence has happened
and when the coherence has happened then
you're not interacting with them anymore
and certainly in a quantum computer the
whole trick is to avoid decoherence so I
think the different parts of the wave
function are interacting with each other
but I would not call them other worlds
other people speak differently and I
know that David Deutsch speaks
differently so that's just a different
choice about what to mean when you say
other worlds but the other thing is I do
think there's an argument here but the
argument is in favor of the idea that
the wave function is real okay to have
Quantum Computing work in the way that
we normally think of it working
it sounds like you need the wave
function to be real I say it sounds like
that because maybe there's some clever
way around that but you certainly talk
as if the wave function is actually a
real thing that is interacting
interfering with itself mattering in
some way okay
there are versions of quantum mechanics
in which the wave function is not real
it's hard to say what to think about
these because they generally won't tell
you what is real but they do say that
the predictions for what you're going to
observe at the end of the day are the
same as in conventional quantum
mechanics so those versions the
epistemic versions of quantum mechanics
would still claim to be 100 compatible
with Quantum Computing because they make
the same predictions as every other
Theory does the shortcomings they're not
telling you what happens along the way
but I think the real problem with this
argument is that there are other
interpretations of quantum mechanics
where the wave function is real but they
are not many worlds hidden variable
theories are that spontaneous collapse
theories are that and so on you're
certainly not ruling out hidden variable
theories or spontaneous collapse
theories on the basis of the existence
of quantum computers so if by arguing
for a proof for the many world
interpretation you literally mean ruling
out the Alternatives I don't think the
quantum computers really do it
Chris wrote Roat says as a former ad
engineer at Google I really like that
you offer a patreon option for ad-free
listening ads are great when you're
searching search ads but terrible when
you want to do other things display ads
like listening to a podcast watch a
video read the news or use social media
the more a Creator's bottom line is
based on display ads the more their
business becomes a murky Cesspool would
you consider some threshold of patreon
subscription counts or subscription
value which would trigger a full ad-free
experience for all listeners
so I appreciate Chris is looking out for
the rest of the world the people who do
not subscribe to the patreon feed he
wants no one to have ads whether they
subscribe to the patreon or not you know
look I get it I think that in many ways
my ad setup is uh better than most it's
you know Wonder e has been very very
good they allow me to turn down a whole
bunch of prospective advertisers I will
not advertise people who make any health
claims about you know supplements or
anything like that not to mention
various anti-sciency things that come
across across the list of possible
advertisers and they've never complained
you know I've been in negotiations with
different web hosting services and
sometimes they demand that you advertise
certain things which I just don't want
to do and it's not that many ads either
there's a certain number once every 15
or 20 minutes you get an ad and so forth
again some of these uh podcasts have a
much higher number of ads than that so I
think that given that there are ads
hours are pretty lightweight and not too
onerous having said that
it is a little bit onerous I get the
fact that you know it's a better
experience overall when you just sail
through the podcast without being
interrupted you know sometimes our ads
are useful like I still use pretty
litter for our cat litter even though
they haven't advertised on mindscape for
years but I get that overall it's a it's
an interruption to the flow of the
argument and look it's more time for me
I have to record the ad I have to embed
it and all that stuff
so I don't want to quote a number but
certainly if the patreon subscription
count was way higher than it is now
um the income from patreon would be
bigger than the income from the ads and
at some point there'd be no point in
doing the ads so even though I don't
know what that number would be
um I can absolutely imagine the patreon
becoming so popular that there's no more
point in me having ads that's pretty
hypothetical right now but that
absolutely could be a possible future so
by all means tell all your friends to
subscribe to the mindscape patreon
Roy Thompson says assuming you record
this episode after the nanograb
announcement on Thursday June 29th do
you have any comments on what they
announce so I'm actually recording this
on June 29th the nanograv announcement
that Roy is referring to is a recent
announcement not just by nanograph but
by some partner collaborations which are
doing Pulsar timing if you remember the
episode we did with Kiara mingarelli who
is a gravitational wave astronomer who
works on the nanograph collaboration
they're using measurements of Pulses
from pulsars throughout the Milky Way
galaxy which are very very precise
clocks okay the timing is really really
on the nose and very very regular so
when a long long wavelength
gravitational wave comes by you know
light years in wavelength it can
slightly move the distance to the
pulsars between us and different pulsars
in a way that you can actually notice by
simultaneously keeping track of all the
signals that we're getting from many
different pulsars scattered throughout
the Galaxy and in principle you can see
gravitational waves that are light years
in wavelength as opposed to the ones we
see at ligo which are kilometers in
wavelength a much shorter distance
and the announcement is that they have
For the First time seen this at a pretty
good statistical significance but not
absolutely completely 100 percent
um settled but it's very very likely
they have actually seen this background
of gravitational waves so what ligo sees
is typically most often what ligo sees
is the end of two in spiraling black
holes okay so you have some black holes
they are tens of times the mass of the
Sun and they spiral in very very close
and they coalesce okay and what you're
seeing is that chirp right at the very
end where these two black holes collide
with each other at the end of a long in
spiraling process now you might ask why
don't you see the whole spiraling in
which also does give off gravitational
waves well for one thing the amplitude
is lower when the black holes are moving
more slowly the gravitational waves are
smaller they're they're lower amplitude
than when they're nearby but for the
other the wavelengths are different when
the black holes are far away their
wavelengths are longer and ligo can't
see them ligo is a four kilometer arm it
is tuned to that wavelength more or less
so nanograv has a much much broader not
not necessarily broader it is broader
but that's not the point longer Baseline
the pulsars are far away light years
away okay so you're looking at much
lower frequency longer wavelength
gravitational waves
so you're not seeing individual events
you're not seeing two black holes
spiral into each other and coalesce
you're seeing a background of many many
binary in spiraling black holes and
because the amplitude is lower when
they're far apart you're seeing binary
supermassive black holes you have to
make up for the fact that they're
further apart therefore the
gravitational waves are weaker by making
them Stronger by having the black holes
be bigger in order to be visible so
there are many such things because
you're not waiting until that last
moment the thing about the ligo events
is you only get a moment to see them
right then they're gone whereas the
nanograph signal comes from binary black
holes that are sort of in stately orbits
gradually doing the same thing for
millions of years before they will
eventually in spiral and uh coalesce so
we're not seeing one or two pairs of
black holes as far as we know we're
seeing a background caused by many of
them
I don't know actually the details this
is too soon after the announcement for
me to have actually looked at any of the
papers
um so had I done this two days ago this
AMA I would have had to say well I don't
know maybe it's this maybe it's that but
my impression is that what they saw is
what they hoped to see okay so there
there's well I shouldn't say hope to see
because maybe they hope to see something
much more dramatic and surprising and
they didn't see that what they saw was
what they optimistically expected to see
let's put it that way which is great
like you know all of these kinds of
things including ligo not and nanograb
they're just the beginning right they're
just the first detection of a new kind
of thing and in astronomy when you look
at the universe in a new kind of way you
always end up being surprised I can't
tell you ahead of time the way in which
we're we will be surprised maybe there
will be more such black holes or fewer
or maybe they're closer or in different
kinds of galaxies maybe we can follow
them up with different kinds of
observations to locate where some of the
individual sources are maybe we will
find different sources of a
gravitational wave background like a
phase transition that is very violent in
the early universe or something like
that or cosmic strings who knows
we're just starting so I think that the
signal that's been seen is makes sense
it's the kind of thing that they were
hoping to see and predicting and we'll
have to see what we learn from further
measurements of that signal
okay I'm gonna group two questions
together one is from Dale Echo he says
inspired by your podcast with t Nguyen I
often hear legitimate scientists say
they have better things to do or they
don't want to give questionable ideas a
platform conspiracy theories anti-vaxx
Etc
this seems reasonable but do you ever
fear that these things already have
platforms and by scientists not directly
engaging and exposing their flaws it
empowers some of the most negative parts
of society and then Oleg rubinsky says
regarding the latest controversy with
Joe Rogan do you think there is an
obligation from a wider scientific
Community to stand up against crackpots
with a wide reach and should this be
somehow better managed in some more
structured manner instead of voluntarily
voluntary like it is now because as you
you yourself mentioned debate and public
rhetoric is a skill you one needs to
work on something for philosophy of
science departments to take on perhaps
yeah you know I think that this is a
difficult question I absolutely think
that there is a legitimate worry about
giving
obviously wrong ideas too much attention
Okay by and this is not just my opinion
this has been shown by people who study
uh information and misinformation and so
forth
for a living when you give attention to
bad ideas those bad ideas very often
become more popular
but that's not Universal or absolute
that I think that there are right and
wrong ways to do this to counter bad
ideas in ways where you're not just
giving them attention you're really
undermining them and showing why they
don't work I do think that
we should have let's say a little more
activity on the part of scientists and
pro science people in combating these
very publicly visible bad ideas it might
not be in the form of a public debate or
something like that but I I do think
that there's a danger that scientists
don't want to get their hands dirty
right they don't want to Sully
themselves by stooping to the level of
these conspiracy theorists and so forth
and some people's minds are made up
that's absolutely clear some people are
just not ever going to change their mind
about this or that conspiracy theory and
I do think that
scientists do that make the following
mistake they they see the people who are
not going to change their minds and they
say to themselves see people never
change their minds so we're gonna ignore
them we're just not going to pay any
attention I think that's a mistake
because there's other people out there
who do change their minds just the fact
that some people won't and some people
are lost causes is usually not the end
of the story It's usually the case that
there's a vast Middle Ground of people
who haven't yet made up their minds and
I do think that those people are worth
reaching out to you know scientists are
accused sometimes of being elitist and
aloof and that's because sometimes they
are elitist and aloof and I think that
that's bad but like you say old like in
the question you know there are bad ways
to do this there's plenty of scientists
who are top-notch scientists and are
really good at understanding how the
world works and how whatever you know
the landing on the moon or vaccination
strategies or whatever and yet would be
bad had at explaining them to people who
are not necessarily open-minded about it
or combating someone who wants to be
against that in some obvious way so you
have to have the right skill set to do
this and I do think that just like for
other forms of Outreach
the field has a responsibility to get
its hands a little dirty in there and
and you know send its best out there to
combat these ideas but individuals don't
because they would probably be doing
more harm than good
you know I do think that
news organizations have at least as much
of a responsibility as scientists do
news organizations very often bend over
a little bit too far to give equal time
to good ideas and bad ideas
news organizations should serve a
function of separating the good ideas
from the bad ideas and you know by all
means if there is a news story cover it
but you don't have to act like
people walked on the moon is equally
viable to people didn't walk on the moon
you can you don't need to get both sides
to that one right and that's Complicated
by the fact that you know the moon hoax
conspiracy theory is not something that
has a lot of support because there's no
vested interests who are interested to
have any incentive to support it but
things like anti-vaxx or climate change
nihilism and things like that these are
bad ideas that have vested interests
supporting them so we need a little bit
more to combat them and I do think that
maybe a debate can play a role in that
but it has to be under exactly the right
circumstances I certainly don't blame
scientists who don't want to
individually get involved with this on
the grounds that they would not be good
at it I think that good for them for
having the self-awareness to know that
that would be bad
Devin Jones says can a black holes
accretion disk be hot enough and have
enough pressure to trigger nuclear
fusion and if so is there any value to
thinking of an accretion disk as sort of
a very flat extreme star
well I the short answer is I don't know
I I suspect I don't see any reason why
in the laws of physics it wouldn't be
hot enough to trigger nuclear fusion so
I suppose it's possible I don't think
there's much value in thinking of it as
a very flat extreme star a star is more
than a place where nuclear fusion
happens it is a gravitationally
self-sustaining quasi-equilibrium place
where nuclear fusion happens so in other
words a star is very specifically a
collection of matter which is in what we
call hydrostatic equilibrium there is a
force of pressure pushing out on the
outer layers caused by the nuclear
fusion at the center and there is a
force pushing in due to gravity and
those forces balance each other and
that's why we say hydrostatic
equilibrium I don't think that anything
like that is likely to happen in the
accretion disk of a black hole so even
if there were nuclear fusion I don't
think it would really be very useful to
think think of it as a kind of a star
Adam rotmill says in reflecting on the
contributions of Einstein and his
contemporaries at the fifth Solvay
conference are there any unresolved
questions or untouched hypotheses from
that era that remain not fully
integrated into our modern understanding
of theoretical physics is there a
particular concept or Theory posited by
Einstein that you believe we haven't yet
fully reckoned with
well mostly the answer is no there uh I
I don't think that that's the right way
to think about Einstein's contributions
at the Solvay conference Etc he was more
or less you know I will defend Einstein
to the extent that he understood quantum
mechanics I actually am on his side
about most of his opinions about it
but his contributions uh other than the
epr experiment obviously the epr thought
experiment and the whole idea of
entanglement which is kind of a big deal
and Einstein should get a lot of credit
for that but in terms of model building
in terms of proposing an alternative to
quantum mechanics as it was understood
at the time I don't think he think that
he made much progress he was more of a
gadfly he was more you know the whole
point of the epr experiment was not to
say here is the right way to think about
quantum mechanics it was simply to say
you're thinking about it wrong okay and
that's that can be a valuable
contribution but I don't think he
offered a clear alternative that was
very compelling
nor do I think that I'm waiting for such
an alternative because I think I have it
in the many worlds interpretation
different people think they have
different versions of it but I think
that we've gone beyond
um Einstein in those ways
as a little tiny footnote here I just
don't like I don't I think that this way
of thinking is probably never very good
this way of saying like oh there was a
brilliant person in the past what were
their insights that we're ignoring now
billion people in the past were
brilliant there's no doubt about that
but almost always we've moved beyond
their thoughts because we've learned a
lot Einstein didn't know about
renormalization and Quantum field theory
he didn't know about black holes there's
a million things he didn't know about
so why in the world would I be asking
what Einstein had in mind and whether or
not we've followed up on that we've
Einstein might be much smarter than I am
but I know a lot more about physics
um in the modern way of thinking about
contemporary fundamental physics than
Einstein did because he's been dead for
a long time so I think that the place I
would much rather ask what ideas some
smart uh 25 year old graduate student
has then ask what ideas Einstein had
today
ARCA Locos says uh ARCA local and I
don't know I can't read the Greek
letters very well
are there any undergraduate level
quantum mechanics textbooks that don't
assume the standard textbook or
Copenhagen approach but rather assume
another interpretation such as hidden
variables or many worlds and would this
make much of a difference for one just
learning the basics of quantum mechanics
I don't think so I I doubt it
um certainly not if you're really
looking at undergraduate level quantum
mechanics textbooks that are meant to be
pedagogical okay I mean you can read
very easily something like David
Wallace's book the emergent Multiverse
uh which will explain to you the many
world's way of thinking about things but
it's not meant as a quantum mechanics
textbook it won't help you solve the
hydrogen atom or something like that
as as I've mentioned I am slowly slowly
slowly working on a quantum mechanics
textbook myself but even mine will not
be you know beholden to many worlds or
any other interpretation of quantum
mechanics because I don't think that
we're done I think that I think that
it's very very likely that many worlds
is the right answer but there are other
smart people who think other answers are
right and so I'm gonna take that into
consideration I'm not my opinions are
not always the end-all of these things
but there's a deeper issue here which is
that it doesn't matter honestly it
doesn't matter which approach you have
which of your versions of the
foundations of quantum mechanics is your
favorite one when you are first learning
quantum mechanics what I call the
textbook approach to Quantum Mechanics
is completely inadequate as a
fundamental theory of nature but it is
completely adequate as a way to learn
quantum mechanics and a way to do
calculations and figure out okay what is
the set of electron orbitals in a
hydrogen atom or something like that
it's fine for that so in my book I'm not
going to be pushing people on many
worlds or anything like that I will have
the current plan anyway is you know an
appendix where I talk about some of the
different possibilities I think that a
lot of
current textbooks say bad untrue things
about the foundations of quantum
mechanics that's not good I want to do
better than that I want to say correct
things but which one you choose doesn't
matter for the purposes of learning
quantum mechanics and doing calculations
simply saying when you make an
observation it appears like the wave
function collapses according to the born
rule is a hundred percent fine all I ask
is that you then admit that can't be the
final answer and when we want to be more
precise and go beyond the level of
calculating hydrogen atom orbitals or
Higgs boson Decay channels then we need
to think more deeply
Christian Hoffman says this question
about black holes has been on my mind
for some time suppose I'm orbiting a
black hole just above its Event Horizon
and I stick my hand in
no matter what I do I will never be able
to pull my hand out again but what would
I actually feel like if I tried I'm
imagining it is like my hand is encased
in a large block of cement and it's
simply pulling the rest of my body
towards it I know you've mentioned
several times that one wouldn't notice
it when crossing the Event Horizon so I
guess my intuition must be wrong here
it's a little bit wrong your intuition
but that's okay I mean most of us don't
have good intuitions about what happens
near the eventualizing of a black hole
um it is true that if the black hole is
big enough
super large black hole you would not
notice when you crossed the Event
Horizon but the thought experiment
you're setting up is not crossing the
Event Horizon right you are outside the
Event Horizon and your hand is inside
that's a different situation
because you can't just say I'm orbiting
the black hole there are no circular
orbits of a black hole right outside the
Event Horizon if you want to be outside
the Event Horizon something has to keep
you there
some Force whether it's a rocket ship or
you know a wire that's attached to
something very far away holding you up
and in that situation if you put half of
yourself or part of yourself your hand
on one side of the Event Horizon and you
on the other side there will actually be
an enormously strong title force a title
Force being the differential force
between different parts of your body so
the short answer is your hand will be
ripped off your body and you would
definitely feel it even though if your
whole body just passed through because
then your whole body is feeling the same
gravitational force you might not notice
anything at all anyway don't do any of
these crazy experiments when if you
actually have a black hole nearby
Leyland Beaumont says what banged what
is your best description of the energy
from which the universe emerged what was
its source its size and its nature
I mean the short and accurate answer
here is that nobody knows it's probably
not even right to ask the question what
banged because the question being bagged
is is there something that banged and
that's not the right way to think as far
as anyone knows about the beginning of
the universe I've said this before but
you know I keep trying to say it using
different words because it has different
resonances for different people
we
don't we are not able to say what
happened at the moment that we talk
about as the Big Bang what that moment
is is an extrapolation into the past
using Einstein's theory of general
relativity and the extrapolation tells
us that if we go into the past there's a
moment of time where the density of
matter and energy is infinite the
curvature of space-time is infinite and
so on
does not mean that the density of matter
was infinite the curvature of space time
was infinite or anything like that it
means that that's the prediction of
general relativity but you're making
that prediction in a regime where you
know general relativity is not right so
what are you doing what are you
expecting the right thing to say is that
there is if you extrapolate general
relativity backwards into the past you
reach a point where you don't know what
happens
that's it that's all you can say now if
your theoretical physicist you can
imagine ways to go beyond general
relativity either with quantum mechanics
or extra Dimensions or whatever
different kinds of things that go beyond
our current understanding and say maybe
it's this maybe it's that and that's
perfectly okay but we don't know is the
short answer we don't know what if
anything there were
we're able to trace empirically what
things were like right after the big
bang a second after the big bang they
have a pretty good idea of what was
going on because the world was doing
nucleosynthesis and we can see their
reaction products from that but actually
at the moment we just don't know we do
know that the there's no need for
anything to have banged as far as
current theory is concerned the universe
could simply have had a first moment the
as far as we know once again the total
charge of the universe is zero the total
energy of the universe is zero you don't
need a source or anything external to
make it happen but like I said we don't
know what actually did
David de bro says in the last AMA you
said decoherence occurs when a system
you are paying attention to becomes
entangled with the environment which is
the degrees of freedom you're not
keeping track of it seems like this
brings subjectivity back into the
definition of d coherence similarly to
how entropy is described in terms of
microstates that appear the same from a
macroscopic point of view I thought many
worlds got rid of such subjective
macroscopic concerns what am I
misunderstanding
I don't think it's true that many worlds
gets rid of a macroscopic element in or
a subjective element in how we describe
the universe at some level
many worlds is simply the statement that
there are wave functions that always
obey the Schrodinger equation that's it
there's no mention of Worlds there's no
mention of decoherence there's no
mention of branching but those things
exist in exactly the same way the tables
and chairs exist even though they are
not mentioned in the standard model of
particle physics that's why David
Wallace's book about many worlds is
called the emergent Multiverse and when
things are emergent and higher level
there will be subjectivity that it comes
in when we talk about how we describe
the macroscopic world how we course
grain it what information we keep track
of what information we don't keep track
of
God does not talk about branches of the
wave function of the universe God just
talks about the wave function what it is
the whole thing all at once but we human
beings with much less information and
much less calculational capacity we find
it useful to talk about branching
because that's where we live that's what
we can observe that's what we can see
but when branching happens is something
that we described much as we described
like you say how entropy increases in a
way that involves some useful subjective
choices once you make those choices once
you say what is the coarse grading that
gets you entropy or what is your
division of the world into system and
environment then everything is objective
then everything just obeys the laws of
physics but in going from the
microscopic world to the macroscopic
description there are some subjective
choices involved and that's perfectly
okay we're subjective people
Joshua hillerup says do you know if
there's research on whether studying
moral philosophy actually makes people
better able to make moral decisions for
whatever better might mean
I'm not super familiar with this but the
I do know that there is research on that
and the answer is it doesn't make people
better uh now the research is not
comprehensive or anything like that but
I do believe that as I vaguely recall
there are studies that you know
philosophy professors who teach ethics
are no better at being ethical in the
real world than regular people are and
in some sense that's not surprising to
me I think that this kind of education
doesn't make you better it makes you
better equipped to be better if you are
already oriented toward being better but
maybe you're not if you're not oriented
toward being a selfless person for
example then being taught philosophical
theories of selflessness are not going
to make you more selfless I don't think
that that should be
um
expected even I think that's not really
I don't think of
[Music]
um
the study of moral philosophy as
intended to make people more moral I
think that it is intended to help people
understand what it means to be more
moral whether they're going to be more
moral is up to them
Sean virtue says I just played a couple
of games one called Fez in which a
two-dimensional character in a
two-dimensional world is granted the
power to perceive a higher Third
Dimension and one called 4D minor in
which the three-dimensional player
character can
three in which the three-dimensional
player character can create a pair of
glasses that allows them to interact
with a higher fourth dimension I believe
they've helped expandability to complex
complex geometry in space-time and I
wanted to know your thoughts on the role
of games in comprehending advanced
concepts in physics
well it depends on what you mean by a
game you know I suspect that the
important aspect of these games is the
simulation aspect or visualization or
virtual reality aspect if we think of a
game as something that has a goal that
you can win or lose that you're you know
oriented towards doing something I don't
think that aspect of it even though it's
fun and I'm all in favor of it is
necessarily pedagogically helpful or
harmful it's just there right but I do
think that the ability to simulate
different circumstances can be very very
helpful in comprehending advanced
concepts in physics I haven't thought
about it a lot you know I've not put a
lot of effort into thinking how one
might do this so I don't think my
thoughts are very well formed but I
wouldn't be surprised because a lot of
the difficulty in comprehending advanced
concepts in physics is that they are
falling well outside our everyday
experience so what a good virtual
reality or visualization can do is help
expand what we have as our experience
background so I'm all in favor of things
like that
Aaron Bowden says Thomas hertog
discussed Quantum effects at the
beginning of the universe and Beyond the
observable universe
but will we return to a Quantum fuzz at
the end of time
you've discussed the big freeze in
previous episodes but do you think that
there will be interesting Quantum
effects when energy densities fall to
zero
in some sense there are but I don't
think that fuzz is the right word you
know what's going to happen is that the
universe will equilibrate it's like a
box of gas coming to its maximum entropy
State when you think about the
macroscopic features of that box of gas
nothing is happening it's just sitting
there
so I think that the important Quantum
effect in the future of the universe
if you believe in many worlds is that
there will no longer be a distinction
between the different worlds because all
of them will look basically the same all
of them will look basically like
equilibrium so there'll be no sensible
way to divide the worlds into different
worlds with different past histories
um once again I haven't thought about
that too carefully but I think that's
the general thing that we would expect
I'm not sure what you mean by
interesting Quantum effects so maybe
that doesn't qualify
says I understand your wife knows
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu what do you know of
Jiu Jitsu and how do you or don't you
understand slash relate to it yeah I
know very little about it like many kids
when I was young I took some lessons in
karate and Judo so I have that kind of
very young not very deep level of
knowledge of martial arts in general but
I have not studied anything about Jiu
Jitsu uh Jennifer has not tried to teach
me anything you know it's something that
you have to dive into it's not something
you do casually and I spend my time
right now doing other things like making
podcasts so I haven't gotten into that
particular thing very carefully
Ahmad chaker says my favorite biggest
ideas in the universe video was your
last one about the philosophy of science
do you ever think you would write a
philosophy of science book
depends what you mean by a philosophy of
science book certainly books that I have
written have an awful lot of philosophy
in them whether it's from eternity to
here or something deeply hidden or the
big picture you know some books don't
have that much like the Higgs boson book
or even the biggest ideas books so far
have been mostly straightforward science
but I mix in philosophy there
if you mean by a philosophy of science
book a
more technical academic book like a
monograph a research book I I could
imagine doing that I have various ideas
about things that I've written about it
as sort of casual popular level that
would be served by taking more seriously
and rigorously and treating them more
academically that could possibly happen
the philosophy of cosmology for example
is a field where I think there's lots of
things to say that uh I could maybe say
some of them anyway maybe there's
something to be said about emergence or
something like that I'm not really sure
I haven't thought about it too deeply if
what you mean by a philosophy of science
book is is sort of more traditional
philosophy of science as meta science as
taking as its study not the universe but
science right Thomas the structure
of scientific revolutions or Paul fire
Robin against method or Carl popper and
you know his falsifiability stuff like
all that is the philosophy of how
science gets done I don't think I'm
going to write a book like that I think
that's important interesting stuff it's
not my biggest interest my interest is
almost always in How the Universe Works
not in the practice of science
Jason Brinkerhoff says while in Rome on
my first vacation in 10 years I had the
great pleasure of seeing Joelle Holmes
play at Gregory's jazz club when you
travel do you often visit jazz clubs do
you have a favorite city or country to
visit for music
not so much to be honest I'm trying to
think if I've ever
um visited a jazz club in Europe or Asia
or anything like that and I can't
remember so it wasn't a very memorable
experience honestly but I do do music
when I travel but but if I'm in Europe
it's much more typically classical music
I think that you know Europe is way
better at classical music than we are
they will have random concerts in uh
church or something like that that are
free and candlelit and it's beautiful
and and lovely to just stumble across
something like that so I do seek that
out and I've had wonderful experiences
there I think probably the jazz is
better here in the United States as far
as I know or at least I know better how
to find it let's put it that way I know
where the good jazz is much better here
so as far as cities are concerned you
know I lived in Chicago for a long time
I very well know where to find the good
jazz there at places like Andes or the
Green Mill or what have you
um and other places like New York it's
just pretty easy New Orleans it's just
pretty easy so I'm definitely interested
in doing that but uh yeah if I'm going
to Europe then it's probably more
classical music if I'm going to Asia
where I've not been nearly as much but
again I'm probably not going to go there
for jazz I did go my one trip to China I
went to the Beijing Opera which is kind
of amazing but I don't have any you know
enough experience there to offer anyone
else any advice about what to do
David Maxwell says is there still space
for individual genius to make intuitive
leaps to change fundamental physics and
cosmology like classical mechanics
relativity and quantum physics or have
our Collective knowledge and resources
advance to the point that all intuitive
questions have been asked in only
iteration remains
you know the thing is you never know
about questions like this if you ask
someone in the year 1800 is there still
space for an individual genius to
overthrow classical mechanics
someone might have reasonably said well
probably not classical mechanics works
really well right they wouldn't have
foreseen quantum mechanics so
it's possible that something like
quantum mechanics will just be true you
know continue to be true indefinitely
into the future but it's also completely
possible that something will come along
that is much more deep and fundamental
quantum mechanics is not going to go
away just like classical mechanics
didn't go away when we invented quantum
mechanics it's a limit of quantum
mechanics sometimes you have a good
scientific theory that you're fond of
and it turns out to be a hundred percent
wrong it's just gotten rid of ptolemaic
astronomy just doesn't really have any
useful remnants to it but other times
you have a good scientific theory where
it might be improved upon or there might
be a deeper Theory underlying it that is
discovered but the theory that you're
fond of is not just going to go away
that's the case for classical Mechanics
for relativity for quantum mechanics but
it's still absolutely possible like I
said that something deeper something
very very fundamentally different will
be discovered someday down the road but
maybe not that's all we can say sorry
Tim Converse says as I understand it the
beckenstein bound limits the information
that can be stored in a region of space
any attempt to store more information in
that region would result in a black hole
does this implication go the other
direction is there a sense in which any
black hole has had a maximal amount of
information stored in it
to be honest I don't like the way of
thinking about the beckenstein bound or
black holes in terms of information
because the word information means
different things in different contexts
and you know there's a sense in which
you can make these statements but
there's a sense in which they're
completely the opposite of true
the I like you know entropy makes sense
to me when you talk about this I I do
think that a black hole is the maximum
amount of entropy that a region of space
can have and probably you know we think
there's good reason to believe that we
can think of that as entanglement
entropy entanglement between the degrees
of freedom inside the black hole and
outside but is having a large entropy
having a lot of information you know in
some sense it's the opposite of having a
lot of information we know nothing about
the system except that it's high entropy
right there's nothing specific that we
know about it if you had specific
arrangements then you would have a lower
entropy situation but I know what they
mean because also you can think of
entropy as counting the number of
degrees of freedom that could possibly
be in this High entropy State and in
that sense there is information
contained in the thing so I'm kind of
avoiding the question because I don't
think it's the right set of words to
attach to these issues
um
but if you switch the question to an
entropy question then we're almost I
want to say yes I want to say that you
know the black hole is the max amount of
entropy you could have in a region and
then you're saying is there a sense in
which a black hole has a maximum amount
of entropy well we're not sure about
that because
we don't understand the microphysics
behind the black holes right we don't
understand what are the degrees of
freedom that we are tracing over or
whatever you want to call it to talk
about the macroscopic framework of the
black hole so it is certainly possible
that it takes time after forming a black
hole for it to become entangled with the
rest of the world it's also possible
that it's pretty quick that it's
essentially instantaneous that's
something that I myself am not going to
opine on but as long as you let the
black hole settle down into its
equilibrium State then yes a black hole
has the max amount of entropy that you
can possibly have in that region
Michael schillingford says in one of
your last podcasts you mentioned the
neither of anyone's later multiversal
descendants are the same person as the
person before the Multiverse split why
do you feel it's that way as opposed to
saying both descendants are the same as
the prior persons or that they are all
the same person but only to a certain
degree
I think that this is just a matter of
improving our understanding our
Precision when we're talking about
self-identity in a world where there is
branching and multiple universes if you
thought there was only one Universe then
personal identity would be a fairly
simple thing not 100 simple but at least
you know you're born you grow up Etc and
then you die and you are one person at
each moment in time now strictly
speaking your different versions of
yourself at different moments of time
are not precisely the same self they
don't have exactly the same memories
exactly the same position in space
they're not even made up of precisely
the same atoms right but there is a
clear convenient sense in which we can
trace some continuity across the years
of your lifetime when you now have many
worlds and each individual person
becomes multiple copies that's no longer
true there is no longer a unique single
person that you can Trace from birth to
death so therefore the fact that even in
the original single Universe way of
talking you really should distinguish
between yourself at 5 pm and yourself at
6 PM as two different people just with
connections between them that goes from
being optional but inconvenient in the
single World case to be necessary in the
multiple World case because otherwise
you start asking well after this
branching happens which one of those two
future people will I be right and that's
not a sensible question to ask because
there's no such thing as which one
you're going to be those are going to be
two people and they're separate people
they can't talk to each other right they
can't interact they're not the same
person by any stretch of the imagination
they've witnessed a different
measurement outcome for whatever Quantum
measurement you're going to do so it
only makes sense to treat them as
different people and in that case you
have to say say that they're different
than the person that they were a few
hours ago again you always should have
said that if you were being careful but
in the many worlds context you have to
be careful if you want to make sense of
what you mean by personal identity in
that kind of many worlds scenario
Robert ruxandrescue says I've been a
materialist all my life but lately I
find idealism as a much better
metaphysical ontological framework
everything is mental and the brain
doesn't produce the Consciousness its
activities just correlated with it the
brain simply localizes Consciousness in
space-time I know that you are a
physicalist but have you considered
idealism yourself
sure I've considered it I find
essentially nothing attractive about
idealism as a point of view so idealism
for those of you who don't hang out on
these particular street corners that
doesn't mean you're idealistic in the
sense that you know you hope for the
best in the world it's idealism in the
sense of taking mind or mentality as
Central to how we think about the
universe at the deepest level as opposed
to physicalism where you think of the
world as a physical stuff and
Consciousness or thinking is just an
emergent phenomenon that comes out of
the collective behavior of certain parts
of that physical stuff so idealism to me
both leans in the wrong direction and
helps with nothing
by leans in the wrong direction I mean
you know we have an idea of what a mind
is we have an idea that your mind is
different than my mind we have different
thoughts we have different uh
ways of thinking about the world
different memories all things like that
and we have different pictures of the
world we have different you know uh
sensory impressions of the world
different models different theories but
guess what the models that we construct
of the world even though we're different
people are extremely compatible with
each other like it's not like I have
general relativity as the true theory of
gravity and you have Newtonian gravity
and we're both right right I mean one of
us might be more up to date than the
other but the world that we claim to be
describing is the same world that just
seems wrong if mentality were first you
know why would it construct the same
world for everyone why not have
different worlds for everybody right so
I think that the now of course you can
fix that you can say well my kind of
idealism doesn't have that you know okay
fine but you're already swimming
Upstream is my point and then the fact
that it doesn't help with anything is
the physical world obey certain rules
right the world has laws of physics they
describe what happens in the universe so
if I'm comparing two scenarios one of
which says
there's just the physical world it does
what it wants to do and the other is
there's sort of some mentality
some Consciousness that exists that is
not simply supervening on the physical
world and the physical world arises out
of that
what does that get me I see I don't
think it gets me anything at all because
I think the people under appreciate the
extension to which Consciousness is
intertwined with behavior
when I think about Consciousness my
Consciousness affects my behavior in a
very definite way I'm conscious of
something therefore I react to it I can
tell you what it is that I am conscious
of that is my behavior and all of that
behavior is a hundred percent well
described by physicalism
so I see no place for anything other
than physicalism to affect that behavior
unless you're really just gonna throw
out all the known laws of physics and
change them in some way in which case
more power to you good luck with that
I've seen no even halfway plausible
suggestions to how that would ever work
but if you could do it then that's fine
and if you don't do it then your
idealism is not doing anything it's just
going along giving you a warm fuzzy
feeling about where all this physical
stuff comes from so I think there's
plenty of hard work to be done in
showing how the phenomena that we
associate with Consciousness and
thinking and Etc are all generated by
physical stuff but that's doable that's
like it's you know that's just science
that's the job that we have in front of
us there's no major obstacle to getting
it done
Anonymous says momentum and position can
be swapped in hamiltonians I've heard
you say does this mean there are
analogies between derived quantities of
position and derived quantities of
momentum
well this is a tricky thing so I have
said things like this if you want to
hear more about what all these words
mean pick up the biggest ideas in the
universe volume 1 space time in motion
because I talk specifically about how to
think about position and momentum and
just the very very brief version is we
typically hear about momentum in our
intro Physics course we say okay there's
a particle let's say let's keep our
lives easy particle classical mechanics
it has a position it has a velocity and
you define the momentum to be the mass
times the velocity and you show that the
momentum of a whole bunch of particles
is conserved over time
in the hamiltonian formulation of
classical mechanics those are not the
words you say and it's kind of
unfortunate that we use some of the
similar words but they mean different
things so in the hamiltonian point of
view you don't say I have a position of
the particle as a function of time I
take its derivative to get the velocity
and I multiply by Mass to get its
momentum what you say is at every moment
in time you have both a position
and the momentum
it says that one moment of time it is
not a derivative it is not a little rate
of change of anything there's something
called the momentum
and then it is not a definition that
momentum equals mass times velocity it
is an equation of motion it is something
that the momentum does it doesn't have
to do it in the world of the classical
way of the hamiltonian way of describing
what the world is momentum and position
are totally separate things but just
like the position of a particle over
time there's many trajectories you could
imagine for it and only one obeys the
equations of motion in the hamiltonian
version of classical mechanics there's
many things the momentum could do and
only one of them is obeying the equation
of motion that is being the mass times
the velocity that's what it is so in
that way of thinking in this hamiltonian
picture
at the deep down level of what
hamiltonian mechanics is there is no
preference for position versus momentum
these are two quantities that are on an
equal footing okay that's what I like to
say positional momentum or on an equal
footing
it's not quite that they can be swapped
that's not quite right you can redefine
uh new variables that effectively swap
them that is true but what I'm really
saying is there's no preference for
positional momentum but that's always a
Prelude to saying of course in the real
world there is a difference between
position and momentum there's many
differences the most obvious one of
which is interactions are local in
position billiard balls bump into each
other when they hit the same position at
the billiard table not when they have
anything to do with each other's
momentum okay so you had to be very very
careful about analogies between derived
quantities of position and derived
quantities of momentum maybe there are
other possible laws of physics other
possible hamiltonians in which they're
on an equal footing but in the actual
hamiltonian of the actual world there's
a clear distinction between position and
momentum and that's okay
nolita s says what do physicists mean
when they say that space and time are on
an equal footing and special relativity
speaking of equal footings it seems to
me that they regurgitate the statement
with little precision as to what they
truly mean would you kindly clarify this
point
sure they mean something very very
precise in fact what they mean is there
is a four-dimensional space time that's
the universe the fort the classical
Universe anyway forget about quantum
mechanics but when you and I talk about
space and time in relativity those are
not things that have any objective
reality they are not absolute in
Newtonian mechanics yes there is
something called space and separately
there's something called space sorry
there's something called space and
there's separately something called time
and you can kind of glue them together
if you wanted to to make space time but
everyone agrees on what is space and
what is time in relativity that's not
the way it works there is one
four-dimensional thing which we call
space time and you can divide it up into
space and time but people will disagree
on how you divide it up into space and
time because there is no absolute fact
of the matter what is space and what is
time separately so you see the
distinction Newtonian mechanics there is
a fact of the matter what is space what
is time you could if you wanted to glue
them together in relativity the only
fact of the matter is that there is
space time
you can if you want to divide it into
space and time but you might not agree
with someone else's way of doing it
there's an infinite number of ways to do
it all of which are equally good that's
what they mean by saying that space and
time are on an equal footing they're
both coordinates on a four-dimensional
space time and different people will
choose different ways of expressing
those coordinates
sorry karapko says after years of
listening to mindscape and especially
these amas I noticed that some of my
opinions become more aligned with yours
not necessarily because I agree with
them but simply due to long exposure I
did have some priors but they slowly
drifted without my conscious effort and
I only notice it comparing my oats from
the past
how do you oppose such a process
yourself especially when it comes to
science is it necessary to balance
exposure to different sources in order
to keep a high degree of intellectual
Independence
well I mean maybe my opinions that
you're agreeing with are just correct
yeah you gotta consider that possibility
at least right but I know you're talking
about
um
to be honest uh
maintaining a high degree of
intellectual Independence is not my
primary goal it's a goal my primary goal
is being right
if somebody else is really really really
right and I listen to them talking and I
find wow you just write all the time and
for good reasons not just for random
reasons for explicable reasons that you
can offer and I can think about and
understand that I'm very happy to take
over you know their points of view that
they've convinced me of I think the
point is not intellectual Independence
but I think the point is knowing why you
believe certain things it's not where
the belief came from or the the
confidence you have in that belief it's
being able to articulate reasons why
those beliefs are yours that's what I
would consider to be important and
that's not a matter of you know
disbelieving or being skeptical or
whatever
um you know as Hugo Mercier said uh
we're actually super good at being
skeptical we're too good at being
skeptical because we're skeptical of
things that we should take seriously too
easily in the world it's not a matter of
being skeptical it's a matter of knowing
what the sources of support are for the
beliefs that you have and to be fair you
know we human beings are very finite uh
very burdened life is short you can't
know everything so sometimes your
reasons for believing things are look
I'm not an expert in this but I trust
this person's point of view about it
that's perfectly okay it shouldn't be
everyone's reason to have certain
beliefs about any certain topic because
some people's job should be to really
think about every possibility and dig
deeply and make sure they know what's
going on but there are just too many
questions to ask in the universe to do
that process for every single possible
question you can ask so again I would
not worry so much about intellectual
Independence as really understanding not
only what it is you believe but why it
is you believe it
James Allen says when giving the
messenger lectures in 1964 Richard
Feynman had a brief aside while
discussing falsifiability he said some
have asked whether space and time were
truly continuous or whether it's some
fundamental scale it was discrete
probably what we now call pixelated and
that it was known that it couldn't be
discreet because it made predictions
which are falsified by observation but
he was in a hurry and never said what
those predictions were or what the
observations that falsified them are and
I've never seen this claim anywhere else
as his desk mate do you have any insight
into what he was getting at was he right
well the way that you say it here is not
precisely correct because of course it's
possible that space-time is discrete
when you put limits on something by
doing an experiment you only limit
something up to a certain degree right
there's a certain Precision in your
experiment if you pixelate the universe
at a sufficiently tiny scale then you
cannot have ruled it out yet so you
can't just say it's been ruled out let's
move on you can say here are the limits
on something like that and there are
limits but guess what those limits are
going to be dependent on the details so
the simplest most straightforward thing
you can do is say okay I have space time
I'm going to literally make it into a
lattice okay so there's a finite
distance between points in space a
finite interval between points in time
I'm going to chunk it up into a lattice
that violates Lorenzen variants that
you're choosing a frame of reference in
which to Define your spatial lattice
right so as a result if you and you can
do this because you can do this on a
computer or something like that right
but you can also do it by hand you can
say if I take a smooth equation of
motion like Maxwell's equation for
electromagnetism and I simply discretize
them and put them on a lattice what
happens and the answer is because you're
no longer relativistically invariant
different frequencies of light will
propagate at different speeds there will
no longer be an exact once and for all
thing called the speed of light that's a
manifestation of the fact that you are
violating Lorenzen variants and this is
something you can look for in
experiments I don't know what the best
limits were in 1964 but there were some
limits today we can do much much better
you can look at generally the thing to
do is to look at something very far away
so if there is an effect that
accumulates over time you're getting the
biggest possible effect the problem is
when you look at something very far away
you're saying well I want a signal in
two different wavelengths of light to
leave at the same time and get to me and
I'm going to ask whether or not they
arrive at the same time
how do you know whether a signal that
came from very far away did leave at the
same time in two different wavelengths
after all if there's something like
burst or supernova or whatever it's
possible that its temperature changes
with time so that it's giving different
amounts of radiation off at different
times but nevertheless you can do it you
can try your best you can work with
gamma rays things that are very very
sharp and well localized in time and you
can look for what are called dispersion
relations that are non-standard that's
just a fancy way of saying different
wavelengths travel at different speeds
so far no evidence for this the world
looks completely The Ransom variant
completely smooth at small scales again
you're just putting a limit on it to
some Precision you're not saying once
and for all forever that's the truth the
other thing is that's just the dumbest
most straightforward way of pixelating
space-time you might be able to do it in
a more clever way that doesn't violate
the rents and variants as much that's
also absolutely possible and guess what
but this is why falsifiability is not
the right way of thinking about
scientific progress it's more
nuanced than that
Rob Petro says in a recent Twitter
exchange you equipped that it's good to
have a manual coffee bean grinder on
hand just in case this leads me to
believe that you are perhaps a somewhat
refined coffee drinker what is your
coffee setup and what recommendations
would you make to someone who likes good
coffee but who's not yet a connoisseur
yeah I think that somewhat refined
coffee drinker is just about exactly
right I'm not a super coffee snob but I
do like good coffee and if coffee is
very bad like you know the giant metal
terrine that you get in a at a hotel in
a conference setup or something like
that then it can be pretty disgusting
and bad but I can still accept and get
pleasure out of a wide variety of
different kinds of coffee espresso
American Coffee Starbucks whatever you
know I have lots of different
possibilities so I'm not that high
strung about it I have throughout the
years gone through just about every
possible way of making coffee and I've
had you know automatic machines that
grind the beans and then make espresso
or whatever I've had drip coffee makers
I've had french press and so forth and
I've settled on like just as simplest
and easiest thing which is the pour over
I literally have my mug which is pretty
big I put the plastic cone on top a
little filter in the plastic cone pour
the coffee on it pour the hot water over
that so there are even though that's
very simple there are a couple of pieces
of equipment you need I think it does
make a difference if you grind your
beans right there if you buy pre-ground
beans that's not going to be as good as
if you grind the beans and then make the
coffee right away so I have a coffee
bean grinder and then you also need a
source of hot water when I was young and
romantic I boiled water in a pot on the
stove that is both highly inefficient
and bad for the environment so now we
just have a kettle an electric kettle
like a good European would have in their
home right and it's actually very
convenient for many things tea as well
as coffee and all sorts of things so
that's the morning routine and then the
only remaining question is
um what is your source of coffee beans
and again you know I looked around I
tried various things and I I'm not a
super expert I've not tried all the
things so maybe I'm missing something
that is would be even better but this is
kind of weird and Goofy sounding but
there is a company called Kicking Horse
Coffee in British Columbia that you can
buy their coffee on Amazon no problem or
directly from them I suppose and of
their Blends or of their beans the my
favorite is one called Kick-Ass coffee
and I literally resisted trying this one
out because the name is so Dopey but
then I tried out other things and you
know the reviews were so good I had to
give in I tried I'm like yeah this is
the best this is the best one I've ever
had so that's what it is kicking horse
coffee again kicking horse if you're out
there listening would love to sponsor
you or you know you have you sponsor the
podcast I can say good things about that
coffee
Josh Dobbin says I'm a Layman reader
listener with enthusiasm but a
relatively shallow understanding of
physics a semi-clever glib thing I put
in a profile description is quote I
currently travel 90 miles per second
around the Sun 136 miles per second
around the Galaxy and 185 miles per
second within the local cluster of known
galaxies I accomplished these
spectacular Feats all while standing
still
but here's my question can I just add
these per second motions up together 96
plus 136 plus 185 equals 417 and
multiply that by the number of seconds
in a year and arrive at the conclusion
that my body is 13 billion miles distant
from where it was in space a year in the
past or am I making some essential error
um you're making two errors sorry about
that Josh uh one is serious and one is
less serious the serious one is that
these are not just numbers you can add
they're vectors because you're moving
you have a velocity so these numbers
that you're quoting 136 miles per second
185 miles per second Etc these are the
magnitudes or the speeds but they're not
the directions
if I am adding together two vectors that
are both a hundred in magnitude but are
opposite in direction then their sum is
100 plus 100 equals zero because their
directions are oppositely aligned so the
same thing true for these Vector
quantities you'll have to add them up
taking into account the direction as
well as the magnitude that's the serious
error but you will still get an answer
even if you did it correctly uh 100 or
hundreds of
um
miles per second 100 what is it miles
per second yeah hundreds of miles per
second is the order of magnitude that
you will get now the other thing that is
that is a less serious error is
relative to what you know there is such
a thing as relativity and in relativity
there's no such thing as an absolute
velocity so all of these are relative to
something so you can fix that mistake
you can say relative to the galactic
standard of rest or something like that
but you would have to fix it you have to
sit down and think about when I'm
quoting these numbers what am I
measuring them with respect to perhaps
with respect to the rest frame of the
cosmic microwave background would be a
perfectly valid thing to do so that's
actually fun I encourage you to do it
you know look up what is your velocity
with respect to the cosmic microwave
background in fact it will be simpler
than what you're doing because
you can just measure it directly I mean
maybe you can't maybe you can no
probably you can't can you measure the
dipole of the the dipole anisotropy of
the cosmic microwave background I think
you can I think that's something like an
experiment you can do without very
Advanced Equipment like if you know what
you're doing you can go off to the roof
of a building and try to do that I think
that's true maybe maybe I'm making that
up you can certainly detect the
existence of the microwave background
but the Doppler shift is one part in a
thousand for it the relative motion with
respect to it anyway you could look up
the number get an approximate value the
high numbers of uh significant figures
here are of course just a fake don't
take the significant figures too
seriously
Daniel Donaldson says during your
discussion with Brian Lowry the concept
of Self in the many worlds
interpretation came up the example you
gave was a person can see a spinning
particle as either up or down which one
is me the answer you gave was neither we
need to update our Notions of self as
we've already talked about in this AMA I
guess I did not understand where you and
Brian went after that my own thought was
that I am me at Time Zero if I see it as
spin up that me continues in the world
another me that saw it's been down
shared my experience up to that point
then has gone off to another adventure
my sense is that in the many worlds
interpretation this is wrong in the self
I am asking for in the end sorry I'm
asking for a more in-depth explanation
of the notion of Self in this context I
should have grouped this question with
the previous one but yes you need a more
nuanced notion of Self in many worlds
you can take your current self and
uniquely trace it backward
you know what happened to you in the
past to the extent that your memories
and records are accurate which is always
a thing but in principle that could be
done but there is no such thing as your
singular self in the future there will
be multiple people in the future all of
which consider your past to be their
past
what vocabulary words do you want to use
to describe that you know go ahead go
nuts at any one moment of time you can
sensibly talk about your actual past and
all of your possible Futures that's what
you have to talk about you cannot talk
about who will I be in which universe
will I end up there is just no such
thing as that
Simon King says if quantum mechanics
represents the true nature of reality
why do we as humans only experience the
world in the classical sense
well that's a difficult question part of
it is is easy which is that we don't
only experience the world in the
classical sense if you've ever heard a
geiger counter much less done a Quantum
experiment of any sort then you've
absolutely experienced the world in a
quantum mechanical sense but I get what
the question is asking about there's
absolutely a classical regime in which
classical mechanics is a very good
approximation to the underlying Quantum
Dynamics why is that true I think that
we actually don't give the right or at
least a complete answer to this when we
take when we teach quantum mechanics and
we talk about quantum mechanics there's
two things that we talk about one is
what is called air invest's theorem if
you have a situation where the pushes
and pulls on a system the force is
acting on it very slowly over space
right like if you're the Earth and
you're orbiting the Sun the sun's
gravitational field does not change
dramatically from place to place so if
that's true and that you are heavy like
the Earth is for example then your
quantum mechanical observables your
position and your momentum do a very
very very very good approximation of
obeying the classical equations of
motion so there's a very well-defined
sense in which quantum mechanics gives
you back classical mechanics in a
well-defined regime now that's only
going to be true it's only going to be
it's always true it's only going to be
relevant if your quantum mechanical wave
function already starts out localized so
if the Earth's wave function were spread
out all over its orbit around the sun
then the fact that its average value of
position momentum behave classically
would be irrelevant it would still look
very quantum mechanical the reason why
that's not relevant is of course
decoherence if you did have spread out
as we talked about already before if you
had a large macroscopic object that is
spread out all over some different
macroscopically observable places then
you very quickly become entangled with
the environment decohere and in each
branch of the wave function it looks
like you're in one particular place
that's also important we don't talk
about that when we teach people quantum
mechanics maybe we should
there's another level of the question
though I mean that those two things
together are the basic answer you would
give
um there's an approximation that is good
and we start out approximately classical
because of decoherence we stay
approximately classical because of air
invests theorem if the system is large
and and so forth macroscopic but
you can ask why the universe both in its
initial conditions and in its laws of
physics allows for classical mechanics
to be a good approximation that is a
much trickier question we have specific
laws of physics that do allow that
specific energies and forces and so
forth the hamiltonian and the technical
way of talking about it and not all
hamiltonians would allow for that so I
actually wrote a paper with ashmeet
Singh the quantum muriology paper where
we do exactly this where we use the
Criterion of looking for classical
behavior in order to figure out how to
divide up the quantum mechanical wave
function into subsystems or into system
and environment for example and we find
there are ways to do it as long as the
hamiltonian lets you do it and the
initial conditions let you do it if they
didn't we wouldn't have a universe which
for which classical mechanics was a good
approximation so this is by the way
another place where the arrow of time
comes in as we talked about before in
this AMA in the future when we reach
equilibrium and there's no Arrow of time
that there won't be anything that looks
classical everything will be in
equilibrium everything will be smoothed
out even the different Quantum worlds
will sort of all blend together so if
that's if that were the world in which
we were in to start then classical
mechanics would not be a good
approximation
there's one final aspect of this
question because Simon says why do we as
humans only experience the world in the
classical sense so
I think the primary answer here is
essentially anthropic in some sense
um classical mechanics allows for
complex systems to come together and
interact in certain ways that can
process information and become conscious
and so forth so basically you could
re-ask this question as if you believe
that there were branches of the wave
function in a many world sense why do we
count as individual observers subsystems
on individual wave functions rather than
combinations of subsystems scattered
across different branches of the wave
function right and there the answer has
to do with the fact that these different
parts of the wave function that are
branched apart don't interact with each
other the things that you would
naturally call observers are localized
on individual wave functions where
things look more or less classical so
that's a complicated answer and if you
get the impression that it's not
completely polished yet I think that's a
perfectly legitimate impression to get
Kyle Stevens says in a recent interval
interview Neil gershenfeld the director
of the MIT Center for bits and Adams
said one of my favorite questions you
can ask a cosmologist to trip them up is
to ask is information a conserved
quantity in the universe is there a
straightforward answer to this question
why might Neil find this a difficult
question for cosmologists well it's not
perfectly straightforward just because
you have to tell me exactly what you
mean by information there's different
senses of the word information so maybe
a cosmologist would hesitate answering
this until you explained exactly what
you meant I think that's perfectly Fair
hesitation if what you mean is the
microscopic information that completely
specifies the quantum state of the
universe then whether or not that is
conserved depends on your favorite
interpretation of quantum mechanics in
many worlds it is overall but you don't
see it being conserved because you only
observe one branch of the wave function
at a time in objective collapse models
it is just not conserved because
collapses of the wave function don't
conserve information I mean this is
famously a question that comes up in
Black Hole physics and the black hole
information loss puzzle is information
really lost and most physicists think
the answer is no they're not thinking
about measurements or collapses of the
wave function they're thinking about the
underlying
Dynamics and and people disagree about
that but at least you would once again
have to tell me what you think is the
best formulation of quantum mechanics to
give a sensible answer to that question
I suspect though that what Neil has in
mind is not the microphysical
information that gives us the exact
microstate of the universe but something
more like accessible macroscopic
information and of course that can be
lost and gained depending on different
physical processes such information is
lost if you just increase the entropy of
something right increased entropy means
that there is a broader class of
microscopic states that might be
represented by your macroscopic state
and if all you know is the macroscopic
state then you have less information
about the system than you used to but
you can also gain information namely by
observing the system right so it's not a
question purely for the universe it's a
question for who is it who has the
information how are they Gathering it
how do they coarse grain all of those
things so I think that it is not a
challenging question at a deep
scientific level it's just a question
that needs more clarification before
you're going to give a precise answer to
it
are quantum Fields really vibrating all
the time due to the uncertainty
principle or do they only vibrate when
they are observed they are certainly not
vibrating all the time due to the
uncertainty principle
um again read book two of the biggest
ideas in the universe or I probably even
talk about this a little bit in
something deeply hidden right there is a
Quantum wave function for the quantum
fields and in the vacuum or in any
stable configuration like an atom or so
forth the fields are not vibrating in
any sense they're completely static
they're the same field configurations
from moment to moment
you talk a language of vibrating exactly
well for for two reasons number one
because the behavior of the fields is
not classical so sometimes people use
the language of vibrations or whatever
to give you a colorful feeling for what
they really mean by Quantum corrections
to classical Behavior radiative
Corrections they will sometimes call
them the other reason is that if you
were to observe you were to make
measurements repeatedly then you would
collapse the wave function and you would
have unpredictable answers when you
figured out what you were seeing and so
it would look like they were vibrating
but when you're not looking there's
nothing vibrating most of the time of
course the fields could vibrate if
they're not in the vacuum or if they're
not in a static State there are things
to change in the universe but there's no
intrinsic jiggliness to Quantum fields
tilo says would you say that
non-deterministic interpretations of
quantum mechanics are compatible with
the eternalist view of time yeah sure I
think everything is compatible with
eternalist view of time it's a slightly
sticky question because if you have a
non-deterministic interpretation of
quantum mechanics that typically means
something like the wave function
objectively collapses for some reason
right and the thing about wave functions
is that they are defined on States at a
given moment of time
that is to say throughout the Universe
At One Moment In Time and as we've
already said earlier in the AMA that's
not a well-defined thing in relativity
who says what is a the Universe At One
Moment In Time different observers might
interpret that separately so I'm not you
know I don't believe in these
interpretations I don't study up on them
very much so I'm not worried about this
problem because I just think that
they're wrong but if I were an advocate
for one of these interpretations I would
worry a lot about when exactly the wave
function collapses as far as different
observers in different locations in the
universe were concerned having said that
um once you pick an answer to that
question you would certainly be
perfectly legitimate in having a
eternalist view of time it's just that
the transitions from the state of the
Universe from one moment to the other
are not perfectly smooth and
deterministic so be it sometimes that's
how things are
Sandro Stucky says I wonder about the
ontological status of density matrices
in Mad Dog aberradianism that
parenthetically is the label that
ashmeet Singh and I gave to the idea of
pure wave function Vector in Hilbert
space realism so no other stuff in your
fundamental ontology other than a vector
in Hilbert space
so Sandro says can we treat a density
Matrix as a fundamental part of the
formalism as real as a pure State a
vector in Hilbert space or are they just
a convenient mathematical device for
representing mixed states does it matter
from a realist stance if we cannot
distinguish different distributions of
pure states that correspond to the same
density Matrix
yeah the answer is I don't know I'm not
even sure if it matters there's a fact
about quantum mechanics so for those of
you who are not Quantum experts a
density Matrix is how in quantum
mechanics we talk about situations where
there is not a pure wave function for a
system in classical statistical
mechanics you have box of gas you say
things like there is some particular
Arrangement right there's some
particular state of all the particles
all their velocities all their positions
we just don't know what it is so we have
some probabilistic distribution function
over possible microstates and that's
enough to make predictions and things
like that in quantum mechanics the role
of that probabilistic distribution
function is played by the density Matrix
you could imagine saying I don't know
which Quantum State the system is
actually in
therefore I'm going to represent it as a
probability distribution over different
possible Quantum States and then there
are some mathematical details as to why
it is something called the density
Matrix rather than just a probability
distribution Over States having to do
with the fact that Quantum states are
vectors and you can add them together
but the different thing in quantum
mechanics is that you can have
entanglement between subsystems you have
if you have two subsystems A and B and
they are entangled with each other
then even if there is a pure single
well-known Quantum state for both A and
B the combined system in general there
is not any pure Quantum State describing
a or describing B they are entangled so
you need the information both to
describe them both at once
but you if you all you want to do are
make predictions for what you will see
when you measure subsystem a you can do
that and the information you need to do
that is precisely the density Matrix of
subsystem a so density matrices are
these probability distributions have a
little bit more of a necessary character
in quantum mechanics in classical
mechanics it's really just because we
don't know all the details in Quantum
Mechanics for an entangled subsystem you
need to talk the language of density
matrices so anyway that was all
background as far as fundamental
ontology is concerned there's a fact
about density matrices that if I have a
system that is not necessarily entangled
but I do describe it using a density
Matrix maybe because I don't know its
exact System state maybe because it is
entangled and I'm just not sure you know
for whatever reason if I am describing
it by a density Matrix which I'm always
allowed to do
I can always what we call purify the
density matrix by imagining that there
is other things in Hilbert space other
than the system I'm considering and
there is some pure Quantum state of the
combined system the system I'm caring
about and the rest of the world there is
always for any density Matrix of
subsystem a there is always a pure state
for that subsystem plus other things
that would give you that density Matrix
so I suspect because of that fact that
you never need to talk about density
matrices but maybe there's some other
fact that I'm not taking into
consideration and I really should that
gives us a reason to prefer to talk
about density matrices at the
fundamental level of ontology uh I don't
know if that's true but I'm open to the
possibility
Peter blankenheim says your recent book
explains that symmetries dictate laws of
conservation for instance a kinetic and
potential energy experiment is the same
if done today or tomorrow at one
location or the other and that gives us
conservation of energy and of momentum
can you explain the reasoning that makes
that necessary
um short answer is no I cannot explain
it here in the AMA it's too complicated
for that I actually struggled with this
in the recently completed book two of
the biggest ideas in the universe
because this result we're referring to
is called nerders theorem after Emmy
nerder the famous mathematician who
proved it in the early 20th century and
you can give a hand away the argument
for why it's true but it's kind of a
mess you know it kind of takes a few
steps to get there and the payoff is
nerd this theorem which is very easy to
state so it's sort of a little bit
tricky to prove but very easy to state
so at the end of the day for the book I
just decided to State it without proving
it uh if you want more details you can
go to the video series on the biggest
ideas in the universe I forget which
video it is but in one of them I do that
hand wavy uh discussion invite is
probably in the one called symmetries
later late in the in the course
um
if I'm trying to you know distill it
down it's just hard to do but what you
need is a continuous symmetry so a
discrete symmetry is not good enough to
for the nervous theorem anyway and also
you need a dynamics that is based on an
action principle a principle of least
action either classically or Quantum
mechanically the quantum mechanical
version would be feynman's path integral
version but so you need a certain set of
ingredients and then you can chug
through just taking some derivatives and
some paths and things like that and you
find that yes there's a quantity that
you can construct so nerve this theorem
doesn't just say there is a conserved
quantity it tells you what it is it
gives you a formula for that conserved
quantity so you can either take my word
for it or go to the video symmetries and
the biggest ideas in the universe
Siddhartha says and I apologize by the
way if you're hearing noise in the
background I'm not sure if you are maybe
it's filtered out but there are people
outside making noise
uh leaf blowers I suppose something like
that I don't know who they are what
they're doing but sorry about that
Siddhartha says I'm trying to understand
how eternalism explains our sense of a
flow of time if all moments of time are
equally real how can we recover the
smooth flow of experiences from moment
to moment is it not better explained by
modifying growing block Universe where
the future is as yet determined as an
eternalism just not materialized yet
I don't think so I don't see why that
would be really uh any benefit at all
because in the philosophical view of a
growing block Universe you still end up
at the end of the day you know after
some time has passed you end up with a
part of a block right which is nothing
more than a set of moments of time okay
physical configuration at different
moments of time and yet every person
every instantiation of a self in that
big block that has already been
constructed had the thought that time
was passing even though they're just
lists of configurations at different
moments in time which is what they would
have been in eternalism so that doesn't
explain the flow of time the
philosophical point of view that says
that what is real is the current moment
and the past but not the future doesn't
help us at all in explaining why we
psychologically have a feeling of the
flow of time that psychological feeling
I'm sure there are subtleties here that
we're not getting into but it basically
comes from at every moment of time you
and your brain carry around an image of
the world that has just passed and the
world that is just about to come you
sort of predict a little bit into the
future and you remember a little bit
into the past and you are constantly at
every moment updating those predictions
and those memories and it's that unequal
comparison between the Impressions we
have of the immediate future and the
projections into the sorry The
Impressions we have the media past and
our projections into the near future
these are different and that's what
gives us the idea that time is flowing
in that particular direction roughly
speaking many details there to be filled
in
Edward Morris says regarding your
conversation with Brian Lowry I'm trying
to understand what the suggestion that
the concept of self could be an entirely
social construction is even supposed to
mean presumably even if you lived your
entire life in solitary confinement with
no human contact the fact that you felt
pain when you dropped something on your
toe but not on the floor would still
give you some at least a rudimentary
sense of being some kind of self behind
your eyes I.E who specifically lived in
your body and not the floor so what is
it that what is sorry so is this not
part of the concept of self that is
talking about or what
yeah you know I'm not the one to defend
it because it's Brian's idea uh not mine
but I think that what he's focusing on
is the fact that so many features of our
identity as a self you know as someone
who is an author and physicist and
podcaster and things like that these
these identities play social roles they
they help tell other people who I am and
I Define myself in with in reference to
what other people would want to know
about me or expect from me given my
various identifications so like I think
that you're probably right I'm not an
expert on this maybe you're not but I'm
probably right that there is some kind
of sense of self that would still exist
if you were raised in solitary
confinement with no human contact but it
wouldn't be an identity in the same way
that psychologists think about the self
that's my reading of it but you know I
tried to understand it better I think I
understand it much better after the
podcast but I still do not understand
the idea 100 percent
Walter Miller says when an electron
falls into a black hole what happens to
that electron's electrostatic field
um sorry the question continues
obviously the portion of that field
Beyond The Event Horizon is no longer
visible to the external Universe does
the black hole wind up carrying a frozen
electrostatic field like the quills on a
porcupine short answer yes that's
exactly what it does by the way same
exact thing with the gravitational field
if I throw a rock with a certain Mass
into the black hole the black hole gets
more mass its gravitational field goes
up if I throw an electron into the black
hole both its mass and its charge change
and now it's electric field and its
gravitational field both are different
the rule that black holes have no hair
has a footnote in it except for unbroken
gauge symmetries which is a fancy
highbrow way of saying long range force
fields we only know of two long range
force fields in nature which are gravity
and electromagnetism so those two things
can both be things that black holes have
and you can easily change them by
throwing things into the black hole
Dory vinette says my bastet who you
wisely and previously noted is a very
good kitty who deserves all the treats
has passed on once I'm ready for the
next kitten what traits would you look
for in a tight tiny baby to help me
choose among all the masses of kittens I
want to take home
I'm sorry to hear the best that has
passed on that's it's always very
difficult when that happens even if we
know that it's inevitable so I hope
you're doing okay
um
I don't have any specific
suggestions about what kind of kitten to
look for because everyone's different
and all kittens are different and all
people are different and they're going
to match up differently my strong
suggestion is to try some kittens out
you know we got Ariel and caliban by
being Foster fails we uh fostered
kittens we've done it more than once
they were they were the first time we
tried fostering so by fostering what it
means is if you have a cat shelter they
will often be overwhelmed because
there's far too many kittens in the
world and they don't have enough room to
have all the kittens especially to give
the very very youngest ones the care
that they need so they will ask for
volunteers to take care of kittens for
you know a month or two just to get them
used to eating solid food and things
like that uh litter trained whatever it
is give them some love and affection
until they're ready to go up for
adoption
there is a whole syndrome called Foster
fails where you say all right I will
Foster be a foster parent to these
kittens and then you don't give them
back you say nope these are my kittens
now and it was pretty clear from the
moment that we got Ariel and caliber and
that was going to be the case
um but we have we subsequently did it
you know we had other Foster kittens uh
during the pandemic when it was just
tough to find people you know we
volunteered and we did give them back
Ariel caliban did not get along with the
newcomers not even a little bit we were
hoping for like a little bit but not at
all they're they're very very
territorial they love each other and
they love us but that's about it
um so we were able to find homes for
those other kittens and either so I
would say you know try fostering if you
want to do that or just go to the cat
shelter and play with the kittens and
see who you bond with right sometimes
the cat will choose you
sometimes you will be you know just your
heart strings will be tugged at by the
Grumpy Cat in the back that doesn't want
to play with anybody but you know
secretly needs love and you can provide
that love for them so I would say don't
go in to the process with any particular
list of requirements figure out uh what
the connection is when you actually make
it
Kyle Hicks says if the direction of the
arrow of time is determined by the flow
of entropy from states of higher order
to those of lower order could biological
open dissipative systems be considered
localized regions in space-time where
the arrow of time seemingly reverses its
direction
no they cannot be considered that
because those open dissipative systems
that are biological organisms or
whatever are very very very heavily
reliant on the fact that entropy is
increasing all around them
it's there's different ways for entropy
to go down as they often say if you put
a bottle of champagne in the
refrigerator and it gets colder its
entropy goes down okay just by the
properties of fluids and that doesn't
mean that the arrow of time is reversed
the arrow of time is more subtle than
that the arrow times not just entropy is
increasing but there's a particular way
in which it's increasing with this past
boundary condition of a very simple low
entropy state in a completely
unspecified future boundary condition
none of that would hold true in a
biological system even if it itself was
going down an entropy if you clean your
room you're not reversing the arrow of
time you're just increasing the entropy
of the universe by putting in the effort
to clean your room and biological
organisms are the same way
Mike Meyer says how sympathetic are you
to the victims of the Ocean Gate
submersible disaster given the high
amount of risk that the passengers
assumed
well I'm very sympathetic I I am not on
board with the people who are sort of
cheering these people who are Risk
Takers and had too much money that they
knew what to do with and so they ended
up in a disaster I think it's still a
disaster and it's still sad especially
because some of those people were you
know the children of grown-ups who made
the decision and they were just trying
to keep their parents happy and it's
it's overall a very tragic thing of
course people who do risky things bear
some responsibility to
um understand that there is a risk there
and especially if you're doing something
where it's Unique and it is not a
well-trodden path and you're spending a
lot of money then you should put in the
work to figure out precisely how much
precaution is taken in you know in the
aftermath of the disaster this is the
submersible that went to look at the
Titanic and imploded and killed everyone
aboard in the aftermath there's plenty
of quotes from the people who had you
know built and run that submersible
which were basically laughing in the
face of danger and safety precautions
and things like that there were a
million red flags saying that this was
not a uh well ordered you know well-run
operation that would be safe to go on
but that doesn't mean that they should
die you know that doesn't mean that we
should celebrate the end of their life
I'm just not uh I'm not I don't see what
the what the gain is there I think it
seems a little bit crass to do that
David witch or white w-y-c-h says the
structure slash dynamics of science
funding in the U.S leads to a few not so
great Downstream effects principal
investigators pis often spend more time
applying for funding than doing actual
science getting a job in the first place
would be more dependent on your skills
as a grant writer than the quality of
your work etc as a wild thought
experiment what do you think would be
the benefits or downsides of just
compiling a list of all the competent
scientific researchers in the U.S
Distributing our vast scientific
research budget to everyone equally and
letting people coordinate on their own
to fund large research projects or not
versus the way we do things now
well I certainly do agree that the
current system could easily be improved
um I think this particular wild thought
experiment would be disastrously bad you
know just giving equal amounts of money
to everyone what do you mean by everyone
you mean literally everyone who asks for
the money whether or not they have even
an academic position or a lab or have
ever written a scientific paper they
just want the money presumably you have
some standards there right so okay now
you're going to start coming up with the
standards do you need to be in Academia
well that's not very fair because there
could be good people outside Academia do
you need to have written papers you know
you have to it's more complicated than
that's going to sound and also there's
just different amounts of Need for money
on the part of different kinds of
science I certainly I apply for money
and I want all the money I can get for
you know Grant proposals and things like
that but there's no sensible World in
which I deserve as much grant money as
someone who is trying to build a
gravitational wave Observatory or a
giant particle those things are more
expensive right so I think you need to
actually just do the hard work you know
one way or the other you have to decide
who deserves the money there's no
shortcut here you have to make that
decision somehow I do agree that the
current system is just far too
bureaucratic right we have to
far too often apply for money and
justify it especially as theorists where
you're supposed to propose you know a
three-year plan of what you're going to
do for the next three years which is
just laughable no one knows what they're
going to do for the next three years so
everyone lies everyone says I'm gonna do
this when they just did it right so it's
a bit of a Kabuki theater there and we
could obviously do better if only by
making the grants uh less frequent and
you know the need for Grant renewal like
there's it doesn't need to be every year
you could just slow it down right and
also I do think that there are some
people who just every single year
they're doing great science just give
them money if they're just doing great
science every year
and that is perfectly clear from their
track record and everyone in the
community knows it why are they spending
time trying to pretend like they're
saying oh here's the great science I'm
gonna do I think that the there's two
categories to which we should just give
people money the ones who are clearly
already doing great science and the
people who are young and just starting
out but very promising and beyond that
we should also have extra money for
people who okay you you've not been
doing great science for a while but you
have a really good idea so let's try to
make that happen too but all of these
little footnotes and caveats add a
little level of bureaucratic necessity
to it so that you see why a current
system like ours comes to be even if
it's not an ideal system
Michael Kramer says uh Einstein's
general relativity question says that
the curvature of space-time depends on
the energy tensor at that point but does
this mean that light by itself I.E
massless but containing energy can cause
gravity yes 100 this is part of the
principle of equivalence that Einstein
used used to inspire himself to invent
general relativity the idea that
everything causes gravity and is
affected by gravity there's no
exceptions to that everything with mass
or energy or existence
causes gravity and in fact it's not just
hypothetical you know in the early
Universe the energy density in photons
was way bigger than the energy density
in matter particles like atoms or dark
matter or whatever we lived in a
radiation-dominated universe
I already talked about the fact that we
have data from primordial
nucleosynthesis when uh the universe was
fusing protons and neutrons into helium
and other Light Elements and that is a
period of time when the universe was
radiation dominated and that fact is
crucially important to getting the right
predictions for the Relic abundance of
helium and lithium and deuterium and so
forth so yes it not only can but it
absolutely does and that's super
important
Gregory kusnick says in an eternal
inflation scenario oops where'd you go
does the bubble of post-inflationary
space that contains our observable
universe have a fixed boundary so that
all its expansion arises from the
expansion of space already inside the
bubble or does the boundary of the
bubble propagate outward through
inflationary space converting more and
more of it into post-inflationary space
that's a good question and it's going to
depend on details usually
the answer is that the region outside
any one bubble a post-inflationary space
is still inflating space right so you
have inflation where you have some very
high energy density in this in this
inflaton field this form of temporary
super high density dark energy
and it rolls down some potential to
become very low energy and reheats into
ordinary matter and radiation and that's
our universe in Eternal inflation that
rolling down happens in one little
bubble but outside the bubble you're
still in this inflationary phase
dominated by this ultra high energy Dark
Energy so energy likes to go down right
or at least you know energy in a low
entropy form likes to convert into
energy in a high entropy form so at the
boundary where you have
true vacuum the the field the inflaton
feels in this low energy State on one
side of the boundary and on the other
side you have false vacuum where the
field is in its high-end energy State
the the boundary between them will move
into the inflating region it will move
in the direction of where the scalar
feel where the inflaton field has a
large false vacuum energy so that tends
to remove space from the inflating
regime but of course inside the
inflating regime the universe is
inflating so it's expanding very very
fast so even though you're removing more
and more space from the inflationary
regime you're also creating more and
more space and that's why inflation goes
on eternally
Ari Maori says do you believe there is a
first cause a cause that there is
nothing else before or does every cause
have a preceding cause if so how is that
even possible
I think that this whole question is
misasked is misformulated
um I don't think that there are causes
at all as part of the fundamental nature
of reality I think that causes our
higher level emergent phenomena it's not
the right vocabulary to use to discuss
the foundations of physics or science or
anything like that and
I don't want to go into too many details
here because I've written about it
elsewhere I wrote a paper called why is
there something rather than nothing and
I detail exactly this or if you want in
a more
um combative version of it I did a
debate with William Lane Craig where he
uses this Aristotelian language of you
know he need a cause for every effect
things like that the principle of
sufficient reason that's just wildly
inappropriate in the world of modern
physics we just don't talk that way
anymore There Are Rules there are laws
of physics but the rules do not take the
form of a chain of causes and effects
the rules are a different kind of thing
they're patterns the question to ask is
not is there a first cause the question
is what do the laws of physics say about
the beginning of and nature of our
universe
Dave grundgeiger says do you think we
should teach modern physics in middle
school I like I feel like I had to
unlearn my middle school science when I
got to higher levels my teachers gave me
the impression that everything was
precise and known in a particular way
but that turned out not to be true EG
the picture of an atom as a mini solar
system is burned in my skull
I'm I think it's okay it would be fine
to teach some Modern physics in middle
school but that doesn't mean that you
need to derive classical mechanics from
quantum mechanics in middle school you
know I think it's perfectly okay to
First teach simpler but more intuitive
approximate versions of reality rather
than going right to the exact you know
the standard model of particle physics
when you're in third grade or whatever
no one should be surprised when you just
have to get to the right answer by a
series of steps rather than just
starting there now having said that you
should teach
the classical physics or whatever the
approximations we use correctly and and
that's just hard to do because Middle
School teachers don't know it they're
not trained for that whether or not they
should be trained for it is a different
question having to do with how we train
teachers and how we credential them and
how we pay them and how much we value
them which in this country is not that
much but right now you know they're
doing their best just to teach you know
baby little physics there you're not
going to get them to teach quantum
mechanics in any Accurate Way
Sean Bentley says my 11 year old Charlie
had a question about what happens to
your acceleration when you approach the
speed of light ignoring the amount of
energy needed to accelerate at these
speeds if you're going
0.9 C and accelerating at 0.1 C per
second does your acceleration slow
before the last second ticks off I'm
pretty sure the answer is no instead the
last second would stretch on to Infinity
due to time dilation
well you know again what are you
measuring your speed with respect to
acceleration is a real objective thing
right that's part of classical mechanics
position and velocity are not objective
they are relative but acceleration is
absolute so the truth is there's a set
of equations that were are part of
Relativity they're part of special
relativity but they were actually
derived before Einstein came up with
this sort of Capstone of Relativity the
by Lorenson Fitzgerald and puancare and
people like that and yes your notion of
both space and time alter at least the
way that you would measure them compared
to someone you're moving with respect to
uh at a very rapid rate so both space
and time change and you keep
accelerating at what to you is exactly
the same amount of acceleration and if
you're measuring the speed at which
other things pass you by they go from
being 0.9 C to 0.95 to 0.96 to 0.97 you
know but they never get to one they
never get to the speed of light they go
up and up and up I should have said you
know from 0.9 C to 0.99 to 0.999 to
0.9999 Etc you get closer and closer you
get asymptotically there uh but that is
because the way that you're measuring
space and time relative to people you're
zipping by becomes a little bit
different
Jeffrey Siegel says I was intrigued by
your skepticism if I interpreted your
Reflections comment correctly regarding
the social self in your discussion with
Brian Lowry it seems to me that the
capability of charismatic individuals to
command unquestioning Obedience of a
large fraction of the population
irrespective of the facts strongly
supports such of you such a social self
could be a selective advantage in human
evolution where competing human groups
needed to survive in the absence of
scientific knowledge do you have an
alternative view of what underlies the
frequent formation of groups such as Q
Anon flat earthers or Maga I think it's
a very complicated phenomenon you know
I'm I'm very skeptical of any purported
explanation for the success of such
conspiracy theories Etc which is too
simple and cheap you know human beings
are kind of complicated different people
might have different reasons for joining
Q Anon and you need to take that into
consideration having said that you know
I think that the closest I've come to
hearing a uh compelling overall theory
of it was in the podcast we did with t
Nguyen about games and the philosophy of
games and and how you sort of there's a
attraction in human beings for simple
clear ways of thinking
and that's not that doesn't sound bad
right simple clear those those are good
things but the point of these conspiracy
theories is they offer Clarity where it
shouldn't be there sometimes like I just
said things are complicated and the
thing about these conspiracy theories is
they have an answer for everything that
is simple and there's a set of people to
blame right uh it's very compelling for
exactly that reason and I remember I I I
was going to say I remember very clearly
I remember reading and I've used this
example before there was a
biography a little Memoir by a woman who
had been a really new AG right she's
into all these woo-woo psychic kinds of
things uh spiritual and in the sort of
uh modern woo-woo kind of sense and but
she was interested about you know what
this is true am I on the right track so
she talked to lots of people and she
eventually became you know hardcore
uh physical I guess physicalist a
naturalist whatever you want to call it
I don't know if she would use those
words but non-spiritual in the in the
sense I'm using it right now
and what I was interested so that's
that's a common story that happens to a
lot of people what I was interested in
was the reason that she gave for her
conversion was that when she talked to
science-minded people there are
questions she could ask to which their
answer was we don't know
but when she talked to her new age
friends every question she asked they
had an answer
and she asked herself like what is a
chance that they actually have an answer
to every single question that I can ask
I mean shouldn't we still be asking
seeking isn't are there more questions
out there but that's the lure of a good
uh overarching conspiracy theory I don't
know if you want to call it new ageism a
conspiracy theory but that kind of thing
where you have Clarity that you didn't
earn Clarity that is reassuring but not
actually reflective of a deep
understanding of anything and I think
that that coupled with various
psychological desires to you know uh
have your in-group be valorized or you
know getting defensive about other
people encroaching on your
Privileges and so forth there's a whole
bunch of aspects that go into why these
uh syndromes are so common
qubit says you mentioned that the
entanglement of a wave function depends
on its decomposition in Hilbert space
however it also seems like two particles
can be entangled in an objective way so
that there is no classical explanation
for their correlations
somehow entanglement seems to depend on
the choice of basis and at the same time
it doesn't can you help
yes I think I can help here I think that
the you know the issue is that you are
saying the words two particles can be
entangled
the point is that in quantum mechanics
if you have a system that we would call
a two-particle system
there is there are ways of describing
that system that do not map onto the
fact that it's two particles I'm trying
to be say use very precise language here
that's why it sounds a little awkward or
clunky here I can find a basis in
Hilbert space where the fact that these
the particle a and particle B is
completely obscured okay so I could find
a so if I have two particles to get a
little bit more technical let's say I
have two particles they're both in
States zero or one so I can have a basis
where the basis elements are zero zero
so particle a is in state zero particle
B is in state zero that's a basis state
so zero zero zero one one zero and one
one those are the basis States right
but there's another set of basis States
0 0 plus 1 1 0 0 minus one one zero one
plus zero one Etc so I can distribute
the entanglement such that the states
that were basis States and would have
seemed entangled are now new basis
States but the different things that I'm
referring to as the subsystems are no
longer the particles okay so the the
reason why it sounds confusing is
because you're taking as objectively
true the fact that you're starting with
two particles
quantum mechanics a little bit more
subtle than that it doesn't necessarily
talk that way of course if you start
with two well-defined subsystems then
asking whether they are entangled or not
is completely objective what I'm saying
is you can change the basis so that the
subsystem decomposition is completely
different in the first place
Eric stromquist says I think you argued
in a 2021 paper the quantum measurements
do not necessarily conserve energy
although energy would be universally
conserved under the Everett
interpretation my question is do you
think this also applies to measurements
of angular momentum two
um no it does not necessarily apply to
measurements of angular momentum it
could but it doesn't necessarily and
probably doesn't and the reason why is
that energy is special in quantum
mechanics it's the thing that appears in
the Schrodinger equation the Schrodinger
equation is H PSI equals i d by DT PSI
and H is the hamiltonian the observable
that corresponds to the energy of the
system
so this idea that uh this was Jackie
lodman and I wrote a paper about it uh
we got published and the idea of the
paper is that you can measure a Quantum
system and that if that Quantum system
is a superposition
of different states with different
energies then in general the outcome of
that superposition will have a different
energy than you had the outcome of the
measurement will have a different energy
than the original superposition did
you might say well what if I start with
the superposition of states that all
have the same energy and that's then it
won't happen right then you're not going
to get a different answer after you do
the measurement than before because
you're just redistributing the same
energy among different states and but
the problem with that is that that's a
system that is not evolving
systems that have a fixed constant
energy don't evolve in quantum mechanics
according to the Schrodinger equation
the only states that interestingly
evolve are those that are superpositions
of states with different total energy
angular momentum or electric charge or
things like that don't work that way you
can just have zero total angular
momentum in the universe or zero total
electric charge in the universe Etc and
that's a perfectly valid way of
constructing a Quantum state it doesn't
say anything about whether it's going to
evolve or not so energy really is
special in quantum mechanics in that
sense
Geodude says what are your thoughts on
open letters calling for moratoria on
Research topics like solar
geoengineering viral gain of function
research and building large AI models do
you think it is wise to Halt research on
certain topics and to what extent is it
possible to shift the focus of the
research community Through top-level
research directives prohibitions or
through social pressure at the level of
individual researchers well there's a
lot of questions going on here a lot of
issues going on here uh you know one is
Is it wise to Heart halt research but
another one is is a good way of doing
that through open letters I I have mixed
feelings about open letters I've signed
a few in my day
um but I don't seek them out I don't
never write them myself I think it's a
very very blunt instrument to use to
make things happen in part because
there's a strong selection effect the
people who write an open letter are
going to be the ones who are most
dedicated right most enthusiastic most
uh really he worked up about the issue
that they're writing about and then
they're going to get other people to try
to sign it who maybe are less
enthusiastic or whatever and inevitably
there's going to be compromises about
the exact wording of the letter and so
on and so forth and the people who are
going to win the discussions about how
to word it are the most enthusiastic the
most you know uh energetically involved
in these topics that doesn't always lead
to the best letters right so I think
it's kind of a blunt instrument in that
sense on the other hand it can work
maybe not because people read the open
letter and then say ah yes we we will do
that we'll do exactly what you say that
never happens but you can get a
conversation started open letters do for
some reason uh seem to have a pretty
good track record at getting people to
talk about these issues certainly an AI
that has happened so maybe okay maybe
you can uh make that argument why it's a
useful thing to do it at least it's
focusing people's attention on the
questions that we care about here now
whether it's wise to Halt research on
certain topics
I think that depends
um I think that a lot of people are just
wildly unrealistic about what it would
mean to Halt research on certain topics
like are you really a hundred percent
okay if your country halves research on
this topic but all other countries don't
because you don't have control over what
the other countries are going to do I
mean there are systems uh in place for
international agreements and so forth
but that's usually not what is being
thought of in these calls for open
letters I think it's very hard to really
Imagine A system that effectively stops
every country from doing research that
would very likely benefit from that kind
that benefit that country if they did
that research
so I'm just not sure how realistic it is
at all you know going back to the
previous discussion we had about
existential risks I think that you know
this is you're hurting your own case by
going too far by saying don't do
research on this topic that's just not
going to happen no that's not actually
going to stop and therefore you're doing
nothing it's because you're saying you
know you're asking for too much you're
going to get nothing why not just have
some sensible safeguards in place right
why not just talk carefully and
realistically about how you can monitor
the research that is being done how you
can funnel research money into
productive areas rather than destructive
ones and so forth I think that kind of
real world
uh careful thought about how to do this
is more productive than an open letter
calling for research to stop but you
know people are lazy people don't want
to do that work that sounds like work
work man like you know protocols to do
research safely like that's boring I
just want to say the world might end
let's stop doing work on this you know
while I continue to do the work in my
backyard so that I can win the race
ultimately so I'm a little skeptical
about calls like that yeah
Anonymous says I'm looking to write some
fun science fiction stories but with an
as accurate a depiction of quantum
behavior in the many worlds
interpretation is possible
with that in mind here's a scenario I
would love your thoughts about Alice has
two photons A and B they are each
prepared in a superposition of up and
down she measures particle a entangling
herself with it but keeps B in its
superposition in the many worlds
interpretation perhaps one could say
there is a branching where Alice sees
Photon a is in the one as up in one
world and down in the other but what
about Photon B still in superposition is
it duplicated but thinner or unbranched
in fat in each world
the answer is if uh A and B are
entangled okay uh maybe I'm reading the
question incorrectly hold on let me let
me think about this again
um yeah so you say Alice has two photons
A and B each prepared in a superposition
of up and down so yeah so it's a little
bit ambiguous here if a and b are
separately in superpositions then if you
measure a then there are now two worlds
one which Alice saw up in Alice saw down
and B is still in a superposition if
they are initially unentangled with each
other but if they are not sorry if they
are entangled with each other then when
Alice sees one the entanglement now
breaks so if if the two particles are in
a an entangled superposition where
either let's say they're both both up
plus they're both down that's the
superposition they're in then after you
measure and let's say Alice sees spin up
now B is in spin up
and they're no longer entangled they're
both separately an unentangled spin-up
States
so if what you're asking is
um so anyway that's a whole bunch of
true statements here
maybe what you're asking is what happens
just to the thickness of the world as
you do these superpositions and this is
a
strange counter-intuitive but true fact
um if you think about the thickness or
thinness of the world that is given by
the amplitude of that world in in the
wave function that amplitude absolute
value squared that's the thickness of
the world so when you do a measurement
of any particle that is in superposition
the thickness of the whole world goes
down because the amplitude of the branch
you're on now is thinner than what it
used to be so that is a global feature
of the wave function this is again one
of the weird things about quantum
mechanics is that the amplitudes of the
wave function are not located anywhere
they are part of the whole wave function
of the universe this fact in fact is
crucially important in understanding
what is called quantum teleportation
quantum teleportation is a way of taking
a qubit so you have Alpha times spin up
plus beta times spin down and if it's
entangled
you can actually move Alpha and beta you
can move the information about what
qubit you have without measuring it or
destroying it okay that seems like magic
but the real reason why is because Alpha
and beta were never really located at
your qubit even if it's not entangled
with anything else in the world they're
still part of the wave function of the
whole universe it's just a weird
non-local feature of quantum mechanics
Patricia Paulson says I've heard you say
how the question we should be asking
isn't why are things non-local but it's
amazing that there is anything that is
local why do you think the idea of
locality is Stranger Than non-locality
well the simple answer is that there are
many many more ways for hypothetical
laws of physics to be non-local than for
them to be local think about it this way
take space
chop it up into regions of space that
are you know one cubic centimeter across
so you have many many cubic centimeters
in the world you've chopped it up into
little regions not literally chopped it
up in your brain you chopped it up so
you can talk about all the quantum
fields in one cubic centimeter and other
cubic centimeter and so forth
locality says that the direct
interactions between one cubic
centimeter and all of the other cubic
centimeters in the universe are only
between nearest Neighbors
when I poke the quantum fields in a
certain cubic centimeter at a certain
location it directly affects the very
closest other fields but does not
directly affect anything going on very
very far away that's a very very special
setup if you imagine all the possible
couplings between that cubic centimeter
and all the other cubic centimeters in
the universe most of them most of the
possible sets of interactions have at
least some interaction between what's
going on here and what's going on Far
Away
being local is being very special it's
like saying I have a list of a hundred
numbers and they just happen to be in
numerical order
right well that's fine but it's very
special like in all of the lists of
numbers you could imagine most of them
are mixed up when you have just local
interactions it's a very small subset of
all the possible interactions you can
imagine
Linus melberg says I've been thinking
about the interview with Andrew
strominger where you talked about the
holographic plate at the boundary in the
infinite future this sounds like
laplace's demon the plate is the state
of the universe in the space dimensions
at fixed time and laplace's Demon can
calculate anything that happened is
there something else needed to make a
holographic plate it seems like there's
something I'm missing
well I'm not quite sure what you have in
mind when you say this sounds like
laplace's demon you know laplace's demon
is supposed to be uh a vast intelligence
you know the past didn't call it a demon
he just said a vast intelligence the
whole point was that you could be smart
enough and knowledgeable enough to
predict the whole history of the
Universe from what is happening at any
one moment
of course the universe itself does that
right according to at least classical or
unitary laws of physics if you know the
state of the universe at one time the
universe does the job of telling you
what's going to happen next but that's
not laplace's demon laplace's demon is
supposed to be an agent right a
Consciousness uh something that is
capable of knowing whereas the universe
sort of just mindlessly chugs along from
moment to moment if there is a
holographic duel to the whole history of
the universe that is located in our
future that's not anything different
than just saying the universe has a
history
and that history can be encoded on a
space-like Surface in the future but
it's not anything knowing it or
calculating it or anything like that so
it's not really very demon-esque
Keith says in the biggest ideas volume 1
and on the podcast you articulate the
broad Strokes of humanism and
anti-humanism with respect to the laws
of nature one way you used to often
refer to the law is one way you used to
often refer to the laws of nature is as
unbreakable patterns this resonated with
my own humble attempts to understand the
laws of nature largely influenced by a
control engineering perspective for
example in optimal control theory
physical laws are often directly
formulated as hard dynamical constraints
my question is where does his
perspective sit in the human anti-human
dichotomy on the one hand it fits well
with the human view but it seems that
these natural constraints might have
more oomph to them than mere convenient
ways of summarizing the world at the
same time I feel inclined to stop short
of the anti-human perspective that the
laws are acting to bring the world into
existence
well I think I'm not gonna be able to
add much here I think that your
impressions are right uh you know you if
you have this perspective from optimal
control theory uh thinking of laws as
constraints I think that you are welcome
to do that from either a human or
anti-human perspective I think that the
existence of constraint laws doesn't
naturally fall into one camp or the
other the tiny little footnote there is
that most anti-humans are thinking of
the laws as bringing the world into
existence over time right helping to
explain how the world goes from the
state of one moment into the state at
the next moment of time whereas
constraint laws do not tell you how to
relate one moment of time to the other
they tell you what can be true at each
moment of time like you know if you
might have a constraint that the total
charge in the universe the total
electric charge is zero there's an equal
number of positive charges and negative
charges that's not helping you explain
how the universe evolves from moment to
moment at all it's just a fact at each
moment I'm kind of human myself so I
don't
um I don't pretend to be an expert in
what an anti-human would say but they
might I don't know they might have
interesting views about constraint laws
rather than dynamical ones
Ken Wolfe says I recently had to do jury
duty and I found the experience
interesting but it got me thinking about
the parallels between the process of
jury deliberation and the process of
scientific investigation I would like to
hear about any experience you have had
on a jury to the extent that you're able
or comfortable but my real question is
whether you had any thoughts on how the
scientific method can inform the process
of Justice in general and the process of
jury deliberation in particular and what
differences you see between the two
well yeah unfortunately I've never been
on a jury I've been called for jury duty
a few times I've gone this is mostly
when I was in uh LA and I would go and I
never got picked I didn't even come it's
not like they questioned me and sent me
away I just sat there for a few hours
and they said okay we're done for the
day we have enough jurors so I guess it
never serves so I can't really speak to
any explicit experience here I do think
that you know science is about finding
the true things that happen in the world
through some kind of hypothetical
deductive method based on empiricism
okay a lot of a lot of buzzwords there
but the idea is you explore different
hypotheses for how the world can be and
then you compare with the data and you
ask which of these hypotheses best
Accords with the data which is very
similar to what a jury is supposed to be
doing there's extra considerations for a
jury because you're not only trying to
find the truth you're trying to fit it
into legal requirements right you're
trying to assign response possibility or
blame or you know Reasonable Doubt
probable cause things like that that
scientists don't have to worry about but
in general I do think that the overall
way that science gets done you know and
having credences of different
um ideas about how the universe works
updating them in the light of new
evidence being careful not to fall prey
to your cognitive biases doing Blind
experiments all of those things are just
good general principles of reasoning
especially about things that happen in
the universe which you're not sure about
so
to how to actually Implement something
where juries are more trained in that
that I don't know that that's a more
difficult social engineering question I
don't have a simple answer to
Rue Phillips says is it common to
consume sorry it is common to consume
violence and sex in the media
I I shouldn't have paused there before
saying in the media Rue is talking about
in the media not just saying that we all
just consume violence and sex every day
some of us maybe
however my anecdotal experience is that
violence is far more acceptable to
tolerate than sex think of how popular
and widely promoted violent movies like
John Wick are and how comparatively rare
it is to see the equivalent acceptance
and popularity of strong sexual content
do you agree and have ideas on why
murder a far greater immoral act is so
much more acceptable to consume than
sexual content I think that the general
impression you have is probably true uh
the way I would put it is I think that
at least here in the United States I'm
not going to talk about other countries
because they're going to be different
and I'm not as familiar enough to say
but here in the US we are more uptight
about sex than we are about violence or
death or other big things like that I
don't think that there's necessarily any
but but also okay so yes I do think that
there is some greater uptightness about
sex and that leads us to be a little
squishy when it comes to allowing sex to
be portrayed on a TV screen or movie
screen that is true clearly it's not
that hard there's plenty of it out there
right
um but I also think that it's a slightly
glib comparison they're not the same
kinds of things the reasons why you
might not want to portray violence on
screen are different than the reasons
why you might not want to portray sex on
screen it's not a simple one-dimensional
scale of morality and say well this is
immoral therefore don't portray it on
screen every movie or TV show has
immoral things happening that is where
conflict and drama come from okay so
it's not as if while we can't show this
because people then go out and do it
um there's different sets of rules being
invoked here I don't have uh time it's
the end of the of the long AMA here so I
haven't thought through how to exactly
articulate the ways in which they're
different but I would say if you care
about this issue I would think in in a
way that tries to be fair to the people
um who are in favor of
having sex having violence but not sex
having sex but not violence having both
having neither are you all these like
try to be fair to all the different
points of view and ask yourself whether
or not you can come up with
a internally consistent moral standpoint
which stands Behind These it would be a
more nuanced one than simply saying
don't show immoral things on screen you
might not want to make people
uncomfortable you might want to not give
them ideas you might want to be
interested in the story and not
something gratuitous there's all sorts
of considerations that you might have in
mind I I don't have a completely well
thought out theory of exactly how much
you should be able to have
Eric dovigi says a priority question I
am an English lecturer at the University
of Arizona we have a great astronomy
program here and I've become very
interested in going back to school for
something in the space Sciences but I
can't decide between planetary Sciences
astronomy physics or math can you help
me decide which field to choose I
understand this is tricky since you
don't know me but any information you
can give me about the job prospects of
different science Fields will be super
helpful yeah I'm not even going to be
able to give you that uh much useful
advice about the job prospects I think
there's two things going on here you
know one is that you need to find your
own match in terms of your own skills
and interests because something like
astronomy and something like math are
very different from each other math is
there's no data collecting in math
there's a lot of data collecting in
astronomy it's mostly data collecting so
the process is very different the things
you'll be thinking about are will be
very different the problems you'll be
solving it's all very very different and
probably
you have in your personality and your
interests are obviously a better match
to one side of that than the other but I
don't know what that is you got to
figure that out for yourself
the other is not only should you worry
about your fit with the different
intellectual activities that we're
thinking of here but you should also
think about like you say the job
prospects how vibrant is the field how
um interesting are the new results like
maybe you think that math is super
interesting but the parts you think are
interesting were all solved in the 19th
century that's perfectly valid in which
case becoming a professional
mathematician aren't is not the right
thing to do
planetary science is certainly a growth
area right now especially if you're in
the exoplanet side of things you know
we've talked about exoplanets several
times I think most recently with John
Johnson
um we're discovering a whole bunch of
new exoplanets and planetary science as
being revitalized exactly because of
that astronomy is astronomy and physics
and math those three are very broad
there's very different kinds of
astronomy different kinds of physics
different kinds of math so there you
would have to really take seriously the
subfields what kind of math are you
being doing geometry or analysis or
whatever what kind of physics condensed
matter particle physics gravity Theory
experiment you know astronomy are you
thinking more cosmology or you can still
do planetary science within an astronomy
department and there's a million
different things to do so I think
there's a lot further that you need to
look into uh to figure out what would be
a good match for you the I will give the
advice I always give which is don't just
think abstractly about the fields really
dig into where you might go for graduate
school so you say it might be at Arizona
for example
look at the actual professors who might
be your advisors and look at the papers
that they have written over the last
five years because science proceeds by
papers being written ask yourself which
of these papers would you like to have
been part of writing or thinking about I
get the impression that in math
collaboration is less common in physics
or astronomy it's very common so PhD
advisors write papers with their
students whereas I think in math the
students like Philosophy for example
also students are more likely to write
papers by themselves so ask yourself
about that also but really dig into what
is the specific work you would be most
interested in being part of
and the last question is from blagoja
olympiaski who says my partner and I are
having our first child congratulations
to decide on whose last name it will
have we are using a Quantum Universe
splitter the idea being that we should
both be happy in one branch of the
universe what do you think of this logic
especially for more serious issues than
the fun one I mentioned well I will
answer it in in the context of the fun
one because I think it matters that it's
a fun one I think that the logic is very
good for the fun one of deciding which
last name or even first name your child
will have the reason why is because
either name is perfectly fine right no
one's being hurt by this and what will
as I very often say you will not be able
to talk to the versions of yourself that
will exist uh you know your your
co-descendants of your past self that
will exist in other branches of the wave
functions you will not be able to
compare notes to see who was happy or
anything like that but the advantage of
this method that you're using is that
you will have a little bit of knowledge
that you didn't have otherwise and that
knowledge can bring you happiness so
let's say I'm not sure whether you'd be
happier if your first child had your
name or your partner's name I really
don't know but let's say you'd be
happier if your first child had your
name
and the universe splitter comes along
and says Nope your first child should
have your partner's name then it is
perfectly valid for you to be happy
knowing that if many world's
interpretation of quantum mechanics is
true there is a version of you and your
family where they have the different
name and it's completely harmless here
in this world for more serious issues
where there really might be a difference
in happiness levels I would not use this
method I would only use it if they were
really exactly a 50 50 uncertainty and
then you would do it just for fun
otherwise do your best to make the right
decision otherwise you might be very
unhappy if the decision doesn't come out
your way and with that thanks very much
for listening once again to the
mindscape AMA remember the new goodies
that we're experimenting with over on
patreon the little video Reflections not
going to happen for the AMA you just
listen to me for long enough but in the
real regular episodes we're going to
start trying to do that see how long it
goes maybe it'll work maybe it won't
anyway thanks once again for supporting
mindscape have a good month take care
bye
[Music]